So, moin Max, bist auch am Start, der Erste heute sogar, hast Glück, der, äh, Feudja, oder wie heißt der, ist nicht da, der sonst immer Erster ist, ja, ExtremelyKegWade,
äh, ich bin übertrieben müde heute, ich bin übelst im Arsch, ich bin erst 18 Uhr heimgekommen, aber gut, ich bin auch über eine Stunde vom Bahnhof heimgelaufen dann, damit ich mich auch noch ein bisschen bewegt hab,
passend live zum frischen Twitch, wie sowas ist passiert, ich hab gar nichts mitgekriegt, wie gesagt, ich bin erst seit 18 Uhr daheim, was ist, das machen wir auch noch, ich hab da, ich kann mich aktuell grad auf so, so Zeug nennen,
ich muss mich nicht richtig konzentrieren, erzähl, wer hat wieder sich mit wem gebeeft, die haben Guidelines für Sponsored Content gedroppt, okay, und das ist jetzt irgendwie kontrovers, oder wie,
boah, das lese ich jetzt nicht durch, was, Streamers may not insert Video-Ads directly into their Streams, die stellen, also, wenn, wenn, wahrgenommen, ich würde jetzt für Hetzer ein bisschen Werbung machen und sage, ich zeige euch jetzt mal,
ein 15 Sekunden Werbeclip,
von, dann darfst du es nicht, oder wie,
ja, das ist ja mal extrem hängen geblieben,
vor allem, theoretisch, ne, Leute,
wenn wir uns jetzt ein YouTube-Video angucken,
und da ist, da ist, äh,
ein Ad drin, dann, dann darf ich das auch nicht zeigen,
ja, ganz ehrlich, aber, wisst ihr was, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was das Gute an Twitch ist,
beziehungsweise an solchen Regeln,
in der Regel,
mag jetzt zwar hart klingen,
aber,
aber in der Regel kräht da kein Hahn danach,
wenn du dich,
an, sagen wir mal,
so,
so dem normalen Menschenverstand entsprechenden Sachen hältst,
juckt's keinen,
und wenn du nicht gerade ein super Aushängeschild bist,
wo irgendwie immer tausende Leute zugucken, die nur drauf warten, dass du mal Scheiße baust, um dich zu reporten,
das steht ja da nicht drin, das steht bloß, man darf keine Werbung zeigen,
das heißt nicht, dass der standardmäßig meinen Stream sponsern muss,
aber gut,
ich muss mir das mal, muss mir das mal in Regel in, in Ruhe durchlesen,
das sah jetzt auf den ersten Blick nicht so, nicht so schlimm für mich aus,
ja,
das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein Problem,
jeder, jedes E-Sport Event,
ich glaube nicht, dass, das nennt, die bezahlen mich ja nicht,
das ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem, da hast du recht,
das, das fühlt sich fast so an, als hat sich Twitch da mal wieder keine richtigen Gedanken gemacht,
also das stimmt wohl,
die ganzen, die ganzen E-Sport Events,
die haben permanent Intel oder sonst was, Werbung laufen,
Looms,
L, L, L, äh,
ich frag mich gerade, wie man das ausspricht,
Loomstick, Loomstick,
Leomstick,
jetzt hab ich mir das eingeschmiert, jetzt hab,
ja, das wirkte tatsächlich jetzt, äh, auf den ersten Blick für mich nicht so wild,
aber es stimmt jetzt, wo du es sagst,
hä,
Streamers may not insert display,
was ist mit den Leuten, die beispielsweise irgendein Energy Drink, ähm,
Logo immer mal wieder einblenden,
wobei das doch anscheinend,
ja, okay, 30%, 3%, 3% of Screen Size,
ja,
okay, das ist alles wieder so ne,
ja, das, das eine blöde Sache an Twitch-Regeln ist ja,
dass die mal so, mal so immer ausgelegt werden,
ja, bis jetzt sieht das doch eigentlich ganz okay aus,
Ich meine...
Aha.
Na gut.
Dass man auf dem Stream keine Drogen
verkaufen darf.
Verbrauchen, beziehungsweise
verbrauchen darf.
Ja, leuchtet mir ein.
Ich habe davon überhaupt nichts mitbekommen.
Bis jemand gepostet hat.
Das finde ich tatsächlich
ganz gut.
Ich habe nie verstanden, warum das so ein großes Ding geworden ist
auf Twitch. Diese ganzen Gambling-Sachen.
Okay.
Das ist natürlich jetzt wieder so ein Ding,
was ultra schwammig ist.
Hateful Products
or Services.
Das ist mega
schwammig. Ab wann ist
ein Product hateful?
Ist das hateful?
Wenn ich Werbung mache
für, sagen wir,
was weiß ich,
Haarfärbemittel?
Weil ich dann Leute
irgendwie...
Alte Leute
diskriminiere oder etwas.
Keine Ahnung. Mir fällt erst kein gutes
Beispiel ein. Aber das ist...
Ich glaube, da ist es schwierig, die Grenze
zu ziehen.
Hateful Stereotypes.
Okay. Wenn ich
mich... Ja gut.
Wenn die das promoten. Okay.
Okay, lass mal überlegen.
Was könnte
da drunter fallen?
Ich meine, mir fallen nur offensichtliche
Dinge ein.
Ja. Dass sie jetzt nicht zum Beispiel...
Für irgendeine rechtsextreme Zeitschrift
Werbung machen darfst und sowas. Ich meine, davon abgesehen,
wer das Vorfeld schon gemacht hat, ist immer ganz dicht
gewesen. Aber gut, ich meine, das ist klar.
Generell, dass du nicht Werbung machen solltest
für was, was in deinem Land verboten
ist, ist auch klar.
Gut, da würde ich im Stream
eh generell von so kontroversen Sachen
würde ich immer generell ganz viel Abstand halten.
Aber ja, das ist wahrscheinlich echt
wieder sowas, wo man sich fragen muss,
ist es nun hateful? Ist es nicht?
Weil es ist ja nicht wirklich...
Hat hier nichts direkt mit Hate zu tun?
Es ist schwierig. Es ist tatsächlich schwierig.
Also schwierig zu sagen, was da alles drunter
fällt. Okay, was darf man nicht
promoten? Weapons. Ja, okay.
Wie? Aber Freedom.
Aber Freedom.
Ich... War wie?
Keine Waffe?
Aber man... Ich denke, ich denke
doch, man braucht Waffen, weil...
Weil... Überlegt euch mal.
Überlegt
euch mal.
Was macht ihr denn?
Das ist jetzt die Ami-Logik.
Was macht ihr denn,
wenn ihr abends in eurem
Wohnzimmer sitzt
und jemand
springt bei euch durchs Fenster
und hat eine SMG dabei?
Das Einzige, was ihr
dagegen machen könnt, ist auch
eine SMG haben oder am besten eine Shotgun,
um den gleich über den Haufen zu schießen.
Also,
nach Kokona-Logik
funktioniert das nicht.
Im GHK.
Irgendwo unterm Sofa, ja? Genau.
Erstmal kreisen und Intervention
scoppen.
Okay, Zigaretten finde ich gut.
Adult-Oriented Products.
Okay, okay, das heißt
allerdings... Okay,
da bin ich mal gespannt.
Was ist das, wenn die ganzen
Boobcam-Leute indirekt
oder auch direkt Werbung
für ihr eigenes Onlyfans machen?
Ich weiß, dass das jetzt eigentlich schon nicht richtig
erlaubt ist, aber...
Male-Enhanced-Products.
Okay, das heißt, für Viagra-Pillen
und sowas darfst du auch keine Werbung machen.
Multilevel-Marketing.
Ja, das ist gut.
Get rich quick.
Wie?
Darf man sich jetzt nicht mehr auf dem Mount Everest
hustlen auf Twitch?
Inside, da hast du schon wieder
was angesprochen. Das ist halt so
ein Ding, das ist wieder
ganz viel Interpretationssache.
Darfst du Werbung
für dein LinkedIn-Profil machen?
Wenn dein LinkedIn-Profil Links
zu Pornoseiten enthält.
Das ist tatsächlich schwierig.
Ich glaube, das kann man...
Das ist ja auch eines meiner größten
Kritikpunkte, die ich seit Jahren
nicht nur an Twitch-Regeln, auch auf YouTube-Regeln,
Twitter-Regeln und sonst was habe,
dass das so einen
weiten Interpretationsspielraum
hat.
Linktree meine ich ja, nicht LinkedIn.
Lull. Na, vielleicht haben manche auch
ihre Porn-Sammlung bei LinkedIn. Keine Ahnung.
Linktree.
Ersätze LinkedIn durch Linktree.
Aber das hat immer
eine super weit
gefächerte Auslegungspalette,
wie solche
TOS-Regeln ausgelegt werden.
Oftmals auch
von wem sie jetzt ausgelegt werden
und für wen sie ausgelegt werden,
dass du teilweise die gleichen
Regeln komplett
gar nicht wiedererkennst zwischen
unterschiedlichen Leuten.
das ist, wie gesagt, das ist ein Problem,
was ich generell bei vielen Seiten sehe.
Klar, du kannst immer sagen, ja gut, das sind ja
denen ihre TOS, die können machen, was sie wollen.
Ja, streng rechtlich gesehen ist das sicherlich so.
Ob das jetzt gut ist? Sei mal dahingestellt.
Ja, das ist aber auf den meisten
Seiten ein Problem, wie das aus, wie die Regeln
letztendlich ausgelegt werden. Und
was ich persönlich auch noch als
weiteres Problem sehe, ist, dass
wenn die Regeln offenkundig
sag mal mal
widersprüchlich ausgelegt werden,
mal so, mal so, dass es im Prinzip
auch keine weitere Instanz gibt,
wo du irgendwie, wo du was
machen kannst. Du kannst dich an den Support
wenden und der Support sagt dann, nee, nee, hat alles seine
Richtigkeit und am besten wirst du gleich noch
gesperrt, hier mal Support-Fälle aufmachen zu können.
Wo gemeint, ich rede nicht von Twitch,
sondern generell von
Seiten, wo Content oder
alle möglichen Services im Internet
das ist tatsächlich schwierig
allgemein.
Political Content,
Paid Promotion für Politiker, Partys,
ähm,
was sind
Issues of Public
Debate? Ist das
Werbung für eine Veranstaltung oder
was? Irgendwie, wenn man sagt,
da und da ist demnächst irgendwie so eine
Kundgebung oder
Veranstaltung von irgendwem, das
oder was heißt Issues of Public
Debate? Fragen
der öffentlichen Debatte.
Was heißt das? Also
ist das die Wildcard für
wir können jeden bannen?
Weil es da drunter fällt. Also ich, ich, ich, okay,
lasst uns mal gucken, language.de,
es gibt es bestimmt noch auf Deutsch, oder?
Ne.
Themen der öffentlichen Debatte.
What the...
Gibt es das nicht auch auf Deutsch, die
Seite vielleicht schon?
Einfach nur die E.
Vielleicht sollten wir es uns mal auf Deutsch angucken, wenn ich zu blöd bin,
es auf Englisch zu verstehen.
Moment.
The- okay. Alter.
Themen der öffentlichen, die ich ver- ich versteh nicht, was damit gemeint ist?
Das kann's ja nicht sein, das ist ja kein Place, meinst du?
Es geht ja hier um Produkte und Dienstleistungen, die man damit nicht bewerben darf.
Was könnte das sein?
Bist du für oder gegen eingesetzt?
Ja, das ist ja nicht verboten zu fragen.
Fragen wäre Werbung.
Okay, das heißt, es wäre verboten, beispielsweise Werbung dafür zu machen,
wenn es irgendeine Volksabstimmung oder sowas in der Schweiz gibt.
So nach dem Motto, stimmt doch alle nächsten Sonntag da und dafür.
Da darf man keine Werbung für machen.
Politik darf nicht auf Twitch sein, dafür ist aber ganz schön viel auf Twitch.
Es geht ja hier um Werbung, Politik an sich.
Warum nicht? Es ist erlaubt, ist ja auch vollkommen okay, dass es erlaubt ist.
Ich meine, ich halte das in meinen Streams so weit wie möglich raus,
aber es gibt genug Streams, die nichts anderes machen,
wie den ganzen Tag zu Circle Jerken hier.
Auf Twitch über irgendwelche Posts von Leuten.
Aber es geht ja um explizite Werbung dafür machen.
Was auch bedeutet, dass du keinerlei Wahlwerbung machen darfst und sowas.
Ja, okay, leuchtet ein.
Cannabis-Produkte, wie jetzt? Ich denke, das ist bald erlaubt bei uns.
Einschließlich Vaping und Abgabesystem.
Ja, okay, soll mir recht sein.
Vape Nation.
Da unten klingt ja irgendwie noch ganz sinnig.
Na gut.
Mal schauen, ich bin mal gespannt.
Also gerade für E-Sport-Streams stelle ich mir das sehr schwierig vor,
wenn du keine Werbung mehr einblenden darfst.
Das macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das wirkt so, als hätte Twitch das nicht richtig durchdacht, diesen Punkt.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, gibt es eigentlich CSU noch.
Schade, dass Werbung für NFTs nicht verboten ist.
Ja, das ist halt auch wieder so ein bisschen Interpretationsspielraum.
Es ist nicht direkt Werbung für NFTs verboten.
Es ist aber verboten, bestimmte Finanzprodukte und Dienstleistungen,
wie zum Beispiel, was im Endeffekt auch wieder heißt,
es ist komplette Auslegungssache.
Also ich meine, die Gesetze, die bei uns in Deutschland erlassen werden,
sind teilweise schon extrem schwammig und wir, woran man auch erkennt,
also nein, man erkennt das ja auch daran,
dass glaube ich, die letzten 5, 5 Jahre, die wir hier in Deutschland haben,
das Bundesverfassungsgericht und so glaube ich, so viel wie noch nie im Vorfeld
irgendwelche Dinger kippen und bestimmen musste, beziehungsweise Vorgaben machen musste.
Aber das hier ist wirklich enorm schwammig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise noch in länger gibt.
Aber das kann ja wirklich alles sein.
Was sind denn Initial Coin Offerings?
Ist das vielleicht sowas wie...
BIKUNE!
Ach, okay.
Ich sign up und ihr bekommt 5 Coins.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay, Multi-Level Marketing ist quasi Pyramiden-Schema.
Ne, wie heißt das?
Pyramidensystem oder sowas?
So, verkaufe unser geiles Fitnessprodukt und werbe neue Leute,
die unser geiles Fitnessprodukt verkaufen und die werben wieder neue Leute.
Was aber auch heißt, wisst ihr, was damit auch verboten ist?
Verboten sein müsste?
Ah, das ist nicht wirklich Multi-Level Marketing.
Aber was auch verboten sein müsste, sind so Keyshop-Affiliate-Programme,
weil ganz viele dieser Affiliate-Programme funktionieren folgendermaßen oder unter anderem
nicht nur, was du selbst quasi verlinkst und verkaufst, wird gewertet,
sondern wenn sich über deine Links jemand registriert und der dann wieder was verkauft,
dann kriegst du bis zu sonst wie zur wievielten Generationen,
was davon ab.
Also das könnte da vielleicht auch runterfallen.
Gut, Get Rich Quick ist ja eh Scam.
Das finde ich gut.
Ja, bei den anderen, da drüben, hier muss man sich erstmal überlegen.
Ja gut.
War da nicht im Knast Anfang des Jahres noch?
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Was nicht zwangsläufig schlecht immer sein muss für Content-Creator,
aber aktuell ist halt das Problem so ein bisschen an dem offiziellen Twitch-Werbeblock,
damit verdienst du halt gar nichts.
Ich wusste nicht, ob Werbung für Suchtmittel,
es wird Werbung verboten für Drogen an sich,
nicht für das Gegenteil, oder?
Ja, aber ich kann irgendwie verstehen, dass sie das Drogenthema nicht auf Twitch haben wollen.
Das ist allgemein auch nicht, sondern ich,
ich werbe freundlich, so.
Der letzte Punkt, okay, einmal gucke ich noch rein.
Ähm, so, wo ist es denn?
Steht auch gar nicht.
Wiederverkauft, die Werbung oder der Handel mit Drogen, Schusswaffen, gefälschte Waffen, illegale Anliegen.
Was?
Sucht?
Ach hier.
Medizinische Einrichtungen wie Verschreibungspflicht der Medikamente, medizinische Studien,
Apotheken, Wundermittel und Suchthilfeeinrichtungen.
Keine Ahnung, warum das verboten ist.
Ich könnte mir höchstens vorstellen, dass es eventuell in manchen Ländern Probleme gibt,
dass sich irgendwelche zwielichtigen Typen und Unternehmen als Suchthilfeeinrichtungen
verkaufen und es gar nicht sind.
Ansonsten, ah gut, ich mein, darfst du dann auch nicht mehr sagen, Leute, wenn euch schlecht geht, ruft die Seelsorge an, oder so?
Ähm, mal was beobachten.
Also, jetzt, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Habt ihr, habt ihr mal reingeguckt bei größeren Speedrunning-Events?
Die dürften dann auch nicht mehr sich sponsoren lassen von Ärzte ohne Grenzen und sowas.
Oder für die, für die, ähm, was, was war beim letzten Event?
Alzheimerstiftung und sowas.
Das sind ja irgendwie eine Art und Weise medizinische Einrichtungen, oder?
Das sind Vereine.
Gilt das nur für bezahlte Werbung oder Eigeninitiative?
Ich hab das Intro gar nicht.
Ich hab das Intro gar nicht gelesen.
Ja, ma, mag gucken.
Im Endeffekt, wie so oft bei Twitch-Regeln.
Meistens geht da eh kein Haar nach,
Seiler nur, seiler nur, du bist so groß, dass du auch genug Hate-Zuschauer hast, die quasi nur drauf warten, dass du Scheiße baust.
Und wenn du ein bisschen aufpasst, ist es eigentlich meistens kein großes Problem.
Ja, mag gucken, was da, was da rauskommt.
Ja.
Ja, ich.
Ja, man interessiert mich, was er zu sagen hat.
Ich gucke mir da aber immer meistens irgendwelche Kurzzusammenfassungen an, wenn es um solche Sachen geht von ihm.
Ich gucke den eigentlich ansonsten nebenbei immer übelst gerne.
Ist einer der wenigen großen Streamer, die ich ab und zu mal gucke.
Aber halt auch nicht oft, weil mich interessiert der Content an sich gar nicht.
Mich interessiert oftmals, was er so zum Besten gibt.
Aber mich interessiert der Content an sich gar nicht.
Weil, da gibt es doch echt Schlimmeres eigentlich.
Ich meine, sein Chat besteht halt zum größten Teil, wenn er was sagt, aus sowas wie True0W oder keine Ahnung.
Aber es gibt deutlich schlimmere Chats.
Guck mal bei XQC mittlerweile rein, das kannst du gar nicht mehr lesen.
True0W.
Wir haben gerade über die neuen Twitch-Regeln gesprochen.
Instagram.
Dankeschön, Insap.
Nun gut, ähm, ja, Chat.
Soll ich euch mal was, was, was, was Witziges erzählen heute von der Arbeit?
Wie immer, anonymisiert.
Erstmal was trinken.
Nicht, dass ich das Hydraten vergesse.
Und dann müssen wir uns mal eine Zusammenfassung angucken.
Oh, was ist das?
Java is mounting a U...
Wait a minute.
Ach, Java 21.
Die haben bestimmt wieder ein paar JavaScript- und C-Sharp-Features geklaut und sagen jetzt neue Versionen besser.
Äh, eigentlich wollte ich mir eine Zusammenfassung angucken von der, von der Apple.
Ja, was war das gestern?
Äh, Pressekonferenz.
Java is mounting a huge comeback.
Alles klar.
Was ist mit dem rechten Typ auf Discord?
Hat der nur etwas...
Hat der nun was erzählt, dass er nicht rechts...
What?
Welcher rechte Typ auf dem Discord?
Bei mir?
Ich hab da schon lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Solange er nicht gegen die Regeln verstößt, ist das ja alles okay.
Ich denke mal, die Modges haben da schon einen Blick drauf.
Sobald er anfängt, irgendwelche Blödsinn zu posten und was gegen die Regeln verstößt, ist er weg.
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Modges machen das schon.
Also, ich hab, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich mein, man sollte vielleicht auch nicht alles, was die Leute manchmal schreiben mit größerem Interpretationsspielraum, gleich, gleich immer auf, muss ein rechter Typ sein.
Also, ich weiß nicht, was er geschrieben hat, ja.
Man ist ja da teilweise echt schnell dabei, gleich zu sagen, oh, hier, ganz, ganz böse rechts.
Man weiß es ja nicht, keine Ahnung.
Also, muss ich mal gucken, was er geschrieben hat.
Aber, also die Mods bei mir auf dem Discord.
Aber die sind in der Regel relativ zackig, wenn es um solche Geschichten geht.
Und wenn er wirklich irgendwas gegen die Regeln geschrieben hat, dann ist er auch, ist er wahrscheinlich schon weg.
Und wenn nicht, wenn er nichts gegen die Regeln geschrieben hat und das nur deine Interpretation ist, also ich verlasse mich da auf meine Modges.
Wir können jetzt nicht, wir können jetzt nicht, ehrlich gesagt, wir können jetzt nicht Discord-Polizei spielen und uns die Profilbilder.
Also, wenn ich die Leute bannen müsste anhand ihrer Profilbilder, dann würde ich die Spiele bannen.
Und dann würde ich die Spiele bannen.
Und dann würde ich die Profilbilder aller Leute angucken und handdessen das was bauen.
Also, sobald die Leute nicht an die Regeln halten auf dem Discord, dann sind sie weg.
Und ansonsten muss man mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich kann nicht viel zu sagen.
Holst du die Apple Vision Pro?
Tja, das ist das Einzige, was ich tatsächlich schon mitbekommen habe von der Apple-Pressekonferenz.
Nämlich, dass die irgendeine VR-Brille haben für 3.500 Euro.
Das ist doch richtig, oder?
Ja, genau. 3.500 Euro.
Ob ich das ausgeben will, habe ich meine Zweifel.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum Apple ausgerechnet jetzt mit einer VR-Brille um die Ecke kommt.
Wahrscheinlich, weil der Hype wieder ein bisschen abgeflacht ist und denkt, die Apple-Leute kaufen eh alles.
Auf der anderen Seite vielleicht auch, da sie jetzt ihre Arm-Based-Plattform haben,
dass sie vielleicht was halbwegs energiesprachendes, halbwegs klein erst jetzt zustande bringen.
Bekommen haben.
Weiß ich nicht. Wir gucken uns gleich mal eine Zusammenfassung an.
Was verwendest du eigentlich für ein Tool, für das könnte sowas auch ein Team sein?
Du meinst das hier?
Ach Leute, wenn man nicht mal Werbung für hasserfüllten Content machen darf.
Leute, ist sowas schon hasserfüllt oder hat Hate-Content mittlerweile?
Fick dich weg, du Robo-Fürst.
Sonst gestorben.
Illustriere ich dir die Eier.
Ist das auch schon Hateful-Content?
Dazu kann ich zu meiner Verteidigung sagen,
falls das irgendjemand jetzt auf Twitter posten will, dann poste das allerdings mal mit.
30 Tage, Mann.
Dann poste das allerdings mal mit.
Der Friseur.
Ihr wisst, der Friseur ist schwul und er hat früher das selbst immer als Beleidigung benutzt.
Oder so als Job.
Auch Beleidigung.
Der hat zu allem und jedem immer gesagt, Homo-Fürst.
Ich glaube, ich glaube sogar, da müsst ihr mal gucken.
Ich glaube sogar, das ist doch in einem oder anderen alten YouTube-Video noch mit drin.
Wo er so Dinger manchmal rausgehauen hat.
Also insofern scheint das ja nicht ganz so schlimm zu sein.
Es sind heute eh alle.
Es sind alle wirklich triggert wegen jedem Scheiß.
Ich denke mir bei vielem, was man sich heute so im Hintergrund durchlesen muss, gerade auf Twitter,
die müssten alle mal 5 Minuten durchatmen und sich beruhigen,
bevor sie quasi wild auf ihrer Tastatur rumschlagen.
Dann würde sich die meiste Sache schon erledigen.
Aber mitbekommen...
Ja, ja, ja.
Also.
Das ist genau...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr...
Das ist unglaublich bescheid.
Das ist genau wie das Okay-Hand-Emoji.
Wo irgendwann 4chan angefangen hat, das zu verbreiten, dass das quasi so White-Power-Symbol ist und sowas.
Und irgendwann, muss man sich mal vorstellen, irgendwann sind dann wirklich Rechte auf die Idee gekommen.
Gerade bei den Amis.
Das zu verwenden.
Also das ist von einem übelsten Troll zu teilweise Leuten...
Gut, die sind eh nicht mehr ganz sauber im Kopf.
Sind die dann wirklich drauf gekommen, das ernsthaft in dem Kontext zu benutzen.
Also, da kann man sich auch nur den Kopf schütteln.
Ja, und das Pepe ist auch sowas.
Ja, das ist echt das Beste.
Weiß nicht.
Ich vermute nicht, dass es um dich geht.
Ich sehe deinen Namen zum ersten Mal.
Das kann nicht um dich gehen.
Ja, ist so ein bisschen, ja.
Poggers, moin.
Radiosignale am Start.
Das ist ja oftmals leider so.
Sobald angefangen wird, irgendwelche Dinger zu verbieten.
Ja, so nach dem Motto, keine Pepe-Emotes mehr.
Dann gehen Pepe-Emotes durch die Decke.
Ja, die drehen überall komplett am Rad.
Wie gesagt, ihr kennt meine Meinung zu dem allgemeinen Empör-Modus, den es in allem gibt.
Im Internet.
Ich bin der Meinung, dass das eher dazu beiträgt, dass das alles noch schlimmer wird.
Nicht, dass das da irgendjemand überzeugt.
Beziehungsweise sich die Leute beruhigen oder danach sagen, oh ja, da denke ich nochmal drüber nach.
Vielleicht könnten die ja doch recht haben.
Das wird nicht passieren.
Also, durch diesen ganzen Empörungsmodus, den alle einschalten, verhärtet sich eigentlich nur alles weiter.
Und im Prinzip bringt das sogar noch eher mehr Leute dazu, irgendwas zu haten.
Weil sie sich auf den Schlips getreten fühlen, die damit überhaupt nichts zu tun hatten ursprünglich.
Also insofern, tja.
Manches ist auch nicht, ist auch nicht alles gut, was im Internet und auf Twitter da so passiert.
Ja, ist tatsächlich so.
Aber alle.
Ich ja auch.
Ich sag ja gar nichts dagegen.
Ich sicherlich auch.
Also ich bin sicherlich auch bei vielen Themen der Meinung, dass das, was ich dazu denke, so das ist das Beste und überhaupt, ja.
Und natürlich lässt man sich auch nicht gerne davon überzeugen.
Dass das jetzt, dass das jetzt Blödsinn ist.
Das heißt, wenn jemand mich überzeugen möchte.
Twitter ist gerade mit.
Das habe ich nur am Rande mitgekriegt.
Wenn mich irgendjemand von was überzeugen möchte, kann ich nur aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, also wenn es, wenn es was ist, wo ich mir schon irgendwie die Meinung zugebildet habe, kann alles Mögliche sein.
Kann.
Wir müssen jetzt gar nicht so weit gehen und irgendwie super krassen Dinger ausbuden und so.
So nach dem Motto.
So, so, so, so, so, so best, bestes, bestes Game 2022 oder so.
Ja.
Oder keine gucken 22 oder oder.
Bestes game aller Zeiten und sowas in der Richtung ja, also oder was ich sowas in der Richtung, wenn es ein Thema ist, wo ich mir schon mal meine Meinung drüber gebildet hat.
Irgendjemand kommt dann, also ich sage ist für mich ist das halt das Beste und irgendjemand anderes kommt dann an und sagt Nein Nein, ihr seid alle scheiße, wenn ihr nicht der Meinung seid, dass das, das und das Game ist.
Ja, gut, ähm, da bin ich eher nicht bereit, mir anzuhören, warum das das beste Game ist.
Weil Niemand lässt sich gerne von anfang an scriben.
Ey.
ey, guck mal, du bist scheiße und jetzt sei mal gefälligst überzeugt von dem, was ich sagen will.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen blöde Mentalität, die sich die letzten Jahre gerade auf Twitter und so in Diskussionen breit gemacht hat,
dass man eigentlich, wenn man nicht super krass ins gleiche Horn bläst,
also wenn man sich nicht versucht noch zu übertreffen gegenseitig mit noch krasseren Meinungen dazu,
zu der Sache, dann ist man gleich schon dagegen und der Feind, ja.
Dabei wollen die meisten Leute eigentlich nur nicht abgefuckt werden den ganzen Tag mit irgendeinem Scheiß, was ihnen am Arsch vorbeigeht.
Sei es jetzt auf Twitter oder im echten Leben, die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich nur ihr Leben leben und ihre Ruhe haben
und nicht zwangsweise in irgendwelche Dinger reingezogen werden, die ihnen am Arsch vorbeigehen.
Und vor allem nicht, vor allem nicht mit, ey, das ist ein Thema, von dem du noch nie was gehört hast
und deswegen bist du dabei.
Bist du da, bist du mega, der Ultraspaß und total scheiße und wie kann das sein, dass du nichts dazu gesagt hast
und du musst dich mal jetzt mal gegenpositionieren und die Leute denken sich nur, hä, um was geht es überhaupt?
Von was sprechen die? Ich, warum bin ich scheiß? Hä, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, um was es geht.
Und dann ist das Erste, was die Leute machen, okay, natürlich, sie sind erstmal instinktiv, finden sie das scheiße,
wo der Typ dafür ist, der ihnen gerade gesagt hat, dass sie kacke.
Und das, also, die meisten Leute wollen eigentlich einfach nur ihre Ruhe und nicht permanent von irgendwelchen Leuten
von der Seite an geranzt werden, von Themen, mit denen sie überhaupt nichts zu tun haben.
Oh, die Katze ist an der Tür, Zack. Ja, ja, Chico. So, wieder da, Katze am Start.
So, jetzt aber genug ans Ringen erinnern. Exzellent.
Ateno, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich glaube, das war auf Twitter schon immer so, nur dass sich das, glaube ich, noch viel mehr hochgeschaukelt hat die letzten Jahre über, ja.
Gerade in der Corona-Zeit, da kamen da auch noch einige dabei, sodass du eigentlich fast schon dich nicht mehr wehren kannst auf Twitter,
es sei denn, also das mitzubekommen, es sei denn, und jetzt kommt, jetzt kommt Lifehack-Beste,
was ihr macht.
Was ihr machen müsst, ihr müsst einfach euer Land, in dem ihr wohnt, auf Twitter umstellen, auf Andorra.
Wenn ihr nämlich in Andorra wohnt, bekommt ihr den ganzen Shit nicht mit.
Ich zeige euch mal den Unterschied.
Also, Twitter, wir gehen jetzt auf deutsches Twitter, ja, und wir stellen fest, dass Zeug strandet, womit ich nicht wirklich...
Okay, der Dauerbrenner, der Lindemann, okay.
Ja, gut, wenn Rand...
Gendarm, natürlich, wenn ich diese Trends schon lese, da weiß ich wieder, ich muss ganz schnell weg von Twitter-Deutschland.
So, und jetzt, passt mal auf, jetzt gehe ich mal auf Twitter, bei mir, ich muss mal hier drauf, so, passt mal auf.
Trends Andorra, ich zeige euch mal meinen Screenshot von meinem Twitter.
Trends Andorra.
So sieht das bei mir aus.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt seriously.
Was ist besser?
Ups.
Was ist euch lieber?
Wenn ihr euch diesen ganzen Müll hier durchlesen müsst in Twitter-Deutschland, oder wenn ihr in Andorra wohnt?
Also, welcher Trend ist euch lieber davon?
Also, ich bleibe in Andorra auf jeden Fall.
Weil ich einer von denen bin, die eigentlich einfach nur ihre Ruhe haben wollen und nicht permanent von der Seite irgendwie irgendeinen Shit mitkriegen wollen.
Wie geht's der Katze, warum hat die einen Verband?
Ist nix Schlimmes.
Also, wahrscheinlich.
Meinst du das hier?
Du meinst wahrscheinlich das hier.
Katze mit Verband.
Ist nix Schlimmes.
Die Katze musste gestern Blut abnehmen.
Beim Arzt, beim Tierarzt.
Und danach kriegt man so nen Klebe-Ding drum, selbst haftenden Verband.
Die musste Blut abnehmen, als Kontrolle.
Wir waren nämlich vor ein paar Wochen schon beim Tierarzt.
Und, äh, Chico, mein Chico ist alt, die ist glaube ich so 13.
Oder so jetzt.
Die hat Schilddrüsen-Überfunktion.
Und, äh, die Nierenblutwerte sind auch nicht so tolle.
Aber das ist im Alter fast normal.
Sie kann's nirgendwas in der Richtung haben.
Und die kriegt jetzt seit, glaub, drei Wochen, kriegt die für die Niere so Flüssigkeit übers Futter.
Das futtert sie tatsächlich auch ganz, äh, also ohne Probleme weiter.
Und morgens und abends kriegt die so ein bisschen Süßkram.
Da ist Schilddrüsen-Medikament drin.
Und das hat richtig was gebracht.
Also, warum ich mit Chico überhaupt zum Arzt bin, lag daran, ähm, also, ich mein, ihr seht's hier vielleicht so, das hier hinten ist ein Klon.
Chico ist jetzt eine relativ kleine Katze, ja.
Und die war, als ich die geholt hab aus dem Tierheim, war Chico auch recht dick.
Ich kann euch jetzt kein Foto zeigen.
Aber, na doch, hier unten rechts, hier unten rechts sieht man's noch ein bisschen.
Aber, ne, nicht wirklich, nicht wirklich gut.
Na, also, jetzt geht's weiter.
Also, als ich die aus dem Tierheim geholt hab, hat die ungefähr 5,5, 5,2 Kilo oder so gewogen.
Da war die recht, recht Chonker-mäßig.
Und die hat jetzt aber die letzten Jahre über kontinuierlich ein bisschen abgenommen.
Hauptsächlich deswegen, weil die bei mir mehr nasses Futter kriegt als Trockenfutter.
Und früher hat die halt so Trockenfutter wie Chips gefressen quasi.
Äh, mir ist langweilig, ich geh Trockenfutter fressen.
Und bei mir kriegt die jetzt ordentliches, äh, Nassfutter, wenn sie's denn frisst.
Manchmal kriegt sie auch übelst nen Lidl-Scheiß, weil sie ihn am liebsten frisst.
Aber, okay.
Ähm, und seitdem hat die immer ein bisschen abgenommen.
Ist jetzt aber seit, seit bestimmt nem Jahr oder so mehr oder weniger stabil gewesen.
So auf, ja, 3,7 Kilo oder sowas.
Was für, was für Chico echt von der Größe und so ein ganz gutes Gewicht ist.
Und die hat jetzt in einem Monat 500 Gramm abgenommen.
Oder in eineinhalb Monaten.
500 Gramm.
Das ist, das ist extrem viel.
Also, das heißt, rein rechnerisch.
Ist die Katze, gibt's die, ist die Katze nicht, hat sich aufgelöst.
Quasi in, äh, 6 Monaten oder so.
So, und, dass das nicht so weitergeht, so weitergehen kann, ist natürlich klar.
Deswegen war ich mit Chico beim Doktor und die haben Blut abgenommen.
Und haben festgestellt, dass die, äh, bisschen, bisschen schlechte Nierenwerte hat.
Und vor allem hat die Schilddrüsenüber, Überfunktion as fuck.
Also, keine Ahnung.
Wenn der Grenzwert irgendwie 10 ist, hatte, hatte, hatte Chico.
Hatte, hatte Chico 50 oder so, ja.
Die hatte ziemlich, ziemlich hohe Werte.
Und, äh, die kriegt jetzt morgens und abends.
Ja, wir wiegen die regelmäßig.
Äh, die kriegt jetzt morgens und abends, kriegt die so ein bisschen Süßkram.
Da ist Schilddrüsenmedikament drin.
Und seitdem sie das kriegt.
Also, die kriegt das jetzt seit 3 Wochen oder so.
Und hat jetzt sogar schon wieder 40 Gramm zugenommen.
Und ist, ist insgesamt auch viel besser drauf, ja.
Weil die, ich hab das schon gemerkt.
So, die ein, die letzten 1, 2 Monate.
Ist sie so richtig, so richtig antriebslos rumgeschlichen die ganze Zeit.
Ich mein, Chico ist alt.
Chico pennt auch gefühlt 90% des Tages.
Das ist normal.
Aber wenn die wach ist, ist die eigentlich immer ganz, ist sonst immer ganz fit gewesen.
Und da hat sie auch die ganze Zeit so übelst rumgeschlichen nur noch.
Und, ja.
Und das, das scheint aber wirklich das Problem gewesen zu sein.
Weil, äh, der geht's jetzt deutlich besser, seitdem die den Kram kriegt.
Und da war ich gestern mit der Katz beim Tierarzt.
Und da haben wir nochmal zusammen geredet.
Und haben zur Kontrolle Blut abgenommen.
So.
Und das abnehmen lassen.
Tierarzt wollte mich eigentlich gestern anrufen.
Haben sie vergessen.
Heute auch nicht.
Also, morgen muss ich ja mal anrufen, wie jetzt die neue, die neuen Blutwerte sind von der Katz.
Wisst ihr, das, das nervt mich auch immer so was.
Wie wenn, wenn irgendjemand sagt, ah, wir melden uns dann.
Weißt ihr, normalerweise frage ich dann immer bei solchen Sachen.
Ja, äh, soll ich heut Abend nochmal anrufen?
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Und wenn's dann als Antwort heißt.
Ja, ja, wir melden uns heut Abend bei Ihnen.
Und dann kommt nix.
Wir schalten ein bisschen auf.
Ich mein, okay, die haben viel zu tun.
Das versteh ich schon.
Ja.
Dann hätten sie zumindest mal heute, heute noch anrufen können.
Oder die hätte irgendein, eine von ihren Helferinnen abkommandieren können.
Mal halt anzurufen und durchzugeben, was Sache ist.
Ja, das find ich immer ein bisschen blöd.
Aber ich versteh ja, dass die viel zu tun haben.
Aber mich interessiert's halt, was mit der Katz ist.
Wie kamst du eigentlich zu, das ist eine schnell beantwortete Frage.
Also, was hat dich dazu gebracht, sie zu anschalten, eine andere?
Äh, das ist tatsächlich relativ einfach zu erklären, wie ich zu Chico gekommen bin.
Also, Chico hab ich aus dem Tierheim.
Bei uns hier in der Nähe aus dem Tierheim.
Und, also, das ist, das ist, daher hab ich Chico.
Warum ich, aber was du, was du wahrscheinlich wissen willst, ist, warum ich ausgerechnet Chico genommen hab im Tierheim und nicht irgendeine andere.
Das ist, das ist auch tatsächlich.
Das ist auch tatsächlich recht einfach zu erklären.
Und zwar, wir machen das anders.
Ich zeig dir das mal kurz anhand, weil, dass man.
So, also.
Ich hab, ich hab hier ja mal ein Video gemacht.
Da sieht man ja alle meine Katzen.
So, hier sieht man Chico.
So, hier sieht man Chico auf dem Schrank.
Hier sieht man Chico, Chico sich umstreicheln, so.
Hier sieht man Chico bei mir in, in Arm beißen.
Guck mal, seht ihr das?
Da war Chico noch eine ganze Ecke dicker.
Vor zwei Jahren.
Also, ich, ich, ich weiß nicht, ob man es richtig erkennt, aber da war noch ein bisschen mehr an Chico dran.
Ja, da war die noch eine ganze Ecke dicker vor zwei Jahren.
So, also, wie ich zu Chico gekommen bin, ganz einfach.
Auf Chico hüpfen wir.
Ja.
Also, das hier ist die erste Katze, die ich hier im Haus hatte.
Die haben wir vom Nachbar damals, ich nenn's mal, ich nenn's mal geerbt.
Ähm.
Der Nachbar ist damals gestorben und die Katze hat im Hof rumgestanden und gemauzt.
Und da hab ich der was zu essen gegeben und, und ein paar Tage später hat sie gesagt, so, ich zieh jetzt bei euch ein.
Und dann ist sie drei Wochen nicht mehr aus dem Haus rausgegangen, weil sie Angst hatte, wir schmeißen sie wieder raus, wenn sie vor die Tür geht.
So, also das ist, das ist Original Katze FPS gewesen.
Die war halt auch schon alt.
Ja, so.
Die gibt es nicht mehr.
Und.
Ein bisschen später, also als es Original Katze FPS dann irgendwann nicht mehr gab, bin ich ein Jahr später oder so ins Tierheim.
Und hab mir die hier ausgesucht.
Die nächste.
Moment.
Die hier.
Die ist richtiger Chonker gewesen.
Ola, Leute.
Die war, die war größer als Chico, aber die, also die war richtig dick.
Man sieht's ja hier glaub ich auch, ne.
Also an der, an der war richtig was dran.
Äh.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich euch schon mal erzählt hab.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich euch schon mal erzählt hab.
Aber ihr seht, also die Katze, die ist schon.
Also die, die, die ist richtig, richtig, richtig.
Richtig Chonker.
Ähm.
Ratet mal.
Okay, ihr kommt nicht drauf.
Vielleicht hab ich's euch schon erzählt.
Wisst ihr, wie die hieß?
Das ist glaub ich so ziemlich der unpassendste Name für diese, für die dicke Katze hier überhaupt gewesen.
Die hieß Barbie.
Aber ich hab mir das nicht ausgedacht.
Und die hat am liebsten.
Die hat am liebsten vorm Fernseh gehockt.
Also Barbie.
Barbie hat am liebsten vorm Fernseh gehockt und hat sich so, so Eichhörnchenvideos angeguckt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr ne Katze habt oder so.
Also, also Barbie hat, stand total auf Eichhörnchenvideos.
So.
Die Sache war die.
Jetzt ganz kurzer Sättgemoment.
Also, ihr seht ja auch, dass die Barbie heißt.
Also wir haben, wir haben die aus dem Tierheim geholt im Frühjahr.
Und eigentlich wusste man schon, dass die krank ist.
Wir wussten nicht so genau.
Also das war auch der, war auch mit ein Grund, weil wir uns gedacht haben.
Ey, guck mal.
Alte Katze.
Die wollen wir jetzt nicht im Tierheim sitzen lassen.
Die ist, der geht's eh nicht mehr so gut.
Die haben wir mitgenommen.
Und die, die, die ist, die hat leider bloß noch ein Dreivierteljahr gelebt.
So.
Und daraufhin.
Moment.
Ja, hier ist wieder Chico am Start.
So.
Und daraufhin, als sie gestorben ist, bin ich nochmal ins Tierheim gefahren.
Und habe auch gesagt, ja, ich bin wieder auf der Suche nach einer Katze.
Und da habe ich mit der gleichen Frau gesprochen, mit der ich mir auch damals Barbie ausgesucht
habe.
Und ich glaube, die hatte ein bisschen ein schlechtes Gewissen, dass wir quasi eine Katze
von ihr bekommen haben, die bloß noch Dreivierteljahr gelebt hat.
Wobei die nicht wirklich was dafür konnte.
Man wusste das ja von Anfang an.
Und die hat uns angerufen dann.
Also wir haben, also wir haben ein bisschen geguckt.
Und die hat uns dann ein paar Tage, nachdem wir im Tierheim waren, hat die uns angerufen,
hat gemeint, es kam gerade eine ganz neue Katze rein.
Ganz furchtbar niedlich und lieb und sonst was.
Und die würde sie gerne möglichst schnell vermitteln, weil die ist auch andere Katzen
und so überhaupt nicht gewöhnt.
Und das wäre genau das Richtige für uns.
Und dann sind wir da hingefahren und dann saß dann halt, saß dann halt Chico da.
Ja.
Guck mal, da war es noch, da war es noch richtiger Chonker hier.
Guckt ihr, seht ihr das?
Seht ihr, wie dick Chico mal war am Anfang?
Guckt mal, wie dick Chico gewesen ist.
Chico war mal richtig, guckt euch das mal an.
Chico war mal richtig dick.
An der war mal richtig was dran.
Ja.
So und so bin ich zu Chico gekommen.
Weil die aus dem Tierheim angerufen hat hier daheim, hat gemeint, es ist gerade hier perfekte Katze für euch reingekommen.
Und da sind wir hingegangen, haben uns Chico angeguckt, haben festgestellt, Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Also Chico hat wirklich, also die darf ja mittlerweile sogar raus auf die, auf die Terrasse, ja.
Da habe ich so einen Vorhang hin, dass sie nicht rauskommt.
Und die hat Schiss vor allem.
Also wenn der, wenn der Nachbar oder wenn von den Nachbarn einer aus dem Fenster guckt, ist die schon auf dem Weg zur Tür.
Oder noch, also was sie immer richtig schockt, die Nachbarin klopft manchmal Teppiche aus auf dem, auf dem Balkon.
Das klopft dann immer so ein bisschen.
Boah ey, da müsst ihr mal sehen, wie schnell die zur Tür rennt.
Die anderen zwei hat es überhaupt nicht.
Die anderen zwei hat es überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Also sowohl die Original Katze FBS als auch Barbie hat es überhaupt nicht gejuckt, wenn da draußen was war.
Ja also, genau, Freigänger.
Das hier, schon immer, also war schon immer, seit Anfang an.
Freigänger.
Und Barbie auch.
Die, also, soweit ich weiß, kam Barbie von irgendeinem tschechischen Bauernhof oder so ursprünglich.
Das heißt, die weiß, die weiß, die weiß.
Das heißt, die weiß, die weiß, wie es draußen ist.
Oder wusste, wusste, wie es draußen ist.
Ja.
Und.
Und Chico.
Wie dick die da noch gewesen ist da.
Barbie schaut gerne, hat gerne Eichhörnchenvideos gehabt.
Chico nicht.
Chico, Chico steht nicht so auf Videos.
Ähm.
So und Chico war eigentlich reine Wohnungskatze.
Wurde, wurde uns gesagt.
Aber irgendwann bin ich auf die Idee gekommen.
Und hab mir so ein Netz gekauft.
Für die Terrasse.
Jetzt nicht so ein Balkonnetz.
Sondern.
Sowas, sowas Spezielles.
Also nicht.
Schutznetze 24.
Keine Ahnung.
Also nicht sowas für ein Balkon.
Sondern.
Hm.
Ich weiß auch nicht mehr, wo ich das bestellt hab.
Zumindest, zumindest was ich gekauft hab, ist folgendes.
Ich hab ein, ähm.
Stahlseil gekauft.
Und ein ziemlich engmaschiges, äh.
So geflechtetes Netz.
So.
Und das Stahlseil hab ich gespannt.
Hab ich halt zwei Haken in die Wand gemacht.
Das Stahlseil hab ich gespannt.
Vorne.
Am Eingang von der Terrasse lang.
Über der, über dem Eingang von der Terrasse lang.
Und da drüber hab ich dieses.
Das Netz gemacht.
Also das, das ist kratz und bissfest.
Das ist katzengetestet.
Das Netz.
Das hab ich da drüber gemacht.
Und.
Jetzt kann man das, wenn man auf die Terrasse will.
Kann man das Netz einfach so zur Seite schieben.
Oben.
Oft über dem, über dem Seil lang.
Oder ansonsten macht man es halt zu.
So.
Ich hab dann unten halt so ein Brett draufgelegt.
Und jetzt kann Chico raus.
Und quasi auf der gesamten Terrasse sich austoben.
Kann aber nicht abhauen.
Weil halt, weil halt Netz, Netz drüber ist.
Du mal dick.
Das fällt mir ja jetzt erst auf.
Meine Güte Chico.
Bist du mal dick gewesen.
Guckt euch das mal an hier.
Guckt euch mal das hier angegen.
Guckt mal hier.
Ich mein außer das hier noch der Bauch ein bisschen hängt.
Aber Leute.
Mega Chonker Chico.
Ziemlich dünner Chico.
Guck mal hier.
Hier ist nix mehr unten.
Das ist, das ist eigentlich alles ganz, ganz normal.
Und hier ist richtige Kugel am Start.
Also hier ist Chico ja nochmal richtig
pipo fett.
Die chonkert.
Genau.
Genug über meine Katze ausgelassen.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, hab ich ja gerade erklärt.
Du wirst erstaunt sein, das sind nicht die einzigen Tabs.
Hier hab ich noch Tabs und hier hab ich auch noch Tabs.
Also.
Guck mal das reicht nicht.
Hier hab ich keinen, aber in meiner VM hab ich noch welche.
Deine da magst wenn man pfeift.
Also meine.
Guck da nur blöd, wenn man pfeift.
So ein bisschen.
Da guckt sie mich an.
Was willst du von mir?
Keine Ahnung. Bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Man kann sich aber auch einfach
gescheites Katzenfutter kaufen mit hohem
Fleischanteil. Das geht ja auch.
Also ich hatte mal Katzenfutter.
Oh ich weiß nicht mal von welchem Hersteller
das ist.
Das war 100%
Thunfisch und 100%
Hähnchen.
Und wenn man das Katzen, also normalerweise,
ihr kennt das vielleicht, normalerweise wenn man
Katzen- oder Hundefutter aufmacht, so dieses
das Billigfutter, also was es vom Lidl
und so gibt.
Das stinkt übelst. Okay für uns.
Ich mein Katzen mögen das furchtbar geil
finden oder so. Das stinkt übelst.
So und ich hab mal so ein
Set gekauft. Ne das war
ich glaub das war Thunfisch und Huhn oder irgendwie
so ne komische Mischung. Ne Thunfisch und Ente.
Das war zumindest hochwertig.
Das hab ich aufgemacht.
Und das hat gerochen so wie als könnte.
Nicht das man es machen sollte.
Aber das hat gerochen wie wenn ich
vom Lidl irgendwie was gekauft
hab was ich jetzt gleich in die Pfanne hauen will und anbraten.
Also das hochwertig,
gut das hat halt ordentlich gekostet.
100% Thunfisch, 100% Hähnchen.
Das war kein billiges Katzenfutter. Also das war
quasi ungefähr so teuer wie wenn ich zum Lidl
gehen würde oder zum
EDK Fleischtheke und sage hier auf
gehts ich will was bestellen. Das hat aber auch
so gerochen wie als könntest du es selbst essen.
Was ich natürlich nicht gemacht hab.
Aber das ist der riesen Unterschied zu einem
billig Lidl Futter.
Katzen können halt richtig alt werden.
Ja so muss
das sein.
9 Babys.
Da will ich mal schnell gucken, dass die
Ratzfatz
sterilisiert, kastriert, was auch immer wird.
Weil ansonsten hast du öfters mal
9 Babys.
Na klar.
Ich hatte jetzt
3 Stück. Also ich hoffe Chico machts
noch ganz lange.
Aber natürlich hole ich mir nach Chico neue Katzen.
Bis ich in Rente gehe.
Warum nicht?
Sogar wie ich klein war fand ich Katzen schon super.
Warum soll ich mir
keine neue mehr holen?
Ich werd mir auf jeden Fall eine neue holen.
Aber wie gesagt,
ich geh davon aus Chico gibts noch eine ganze Weile.
Vielleicht
hole ich ja auch Chico irgendwann
nochmal eine zweite.
Also der Grund warum ich keine zweite hab bei Chico ist
ähm
Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Und Chico das hat man im Tierheim. Die haben das im Tierheim
ausprobiert. Die haben auch explizit gesagt
das ist tatsächlich eine Katze die als Einzelkatze
die Einzelkatze sein will.
Normalerweise sagt man immer Katzen ist viel zu langweilig
alleine und sowas. Und es ist viel besser
zu zweit. Aber Chico hat Schiss
vor allem.
Und die hat, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Im Tierheim
saß die in ihrem Käfig drinne
und da war so eine kleine freche
Babykatze, die da rumgeflitzt
ist.
Die war, keine Ahnung
10 cm groß oder so.
Das war, das war
Mini Katze die da rumgeflitzt ist.
Und
die ist dann irgendwann hochgeklettert
und bei Chico in die Box gehüpft.
Also in den Käfig gehüpft im Tierheim
wo Chico auch drin war. Die haben das so
gemacht irgendwie
das irgendwie ab und zu mal am Tag wurde das
alles aufgemacht. Da konnten die Katzen ein bisschen
rumstelzen und so.
Und Chico hat sich da schon nicht raus getraut.
Und da ist diese 10 cm
Babykatze
in den Käfig
von Chico gehüpft.
Und was hat Chico gemacht?
Also alle meine anderen zwei hätten folgendes gemacht.
Die hätten an der Babykatze geschnuppert
und hätten sich gedacht, ah ja gut
solange die nicht an mein Futter geht, juckt es mich nicht.
Was Chico gemacht hat ist
Chico ist auf die höchste
Ebene in ihrem Käfig
gekrabbelt, in ihren Korb
rein und hat angefangen zu fauchen.
Vorne 10 cm
Babykatze.
Und Chico hat, ohne Spaß,
Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Wenn ich zu schnell durch den
Flur laufe, rennt sie.
Gut, bei mir hat sie sich jetzt mittlerweile
schon dran gewöhnt, aber am Anfang
also ich weiß nicht, was die mit der gemacht haben
wo die herkommt, aber Chico
hat wirklich Schiss vor allem.
Leute, könnt ihr euch vorstellen, Chico
hat Angst vor Flummis.
Normalerweise, also alle Katzen die ich bisher
hatte und kannte, fanden Flummis
was ganz tolles.
Flummis ist das Beste.
Chico hat Angst vor Flummis.
Ich nehme
den Flummi und werfe
den so nicht schnell, so langsam in den Flur
der duppt einmal auf
der Flummi und Chico rennt
in die entgegengesetzte Richtung weg.
Also Chico hat Schiss vor allem.
Also ich kann mir das nur
so erklären, dass die
ähm, dass wo
die hergekommen ist, dass
sie die nicht gut behandelt haben müssen, sonst würde
ich nicht verstehen, warum es da so steht.
Also das muss ich sagen,
die haben uns Chico tatsächlich damals
im Tierheim, die haben wirklich gesagt, das ist die Ausnahme,
Chico ist reine Hauskatze
und Chico mag gar keine
anderen Tiere und hat
Angst vor anderen Tieren.
Aber ich muss sagen,
seitdem ich
Chico rauslasse auf die Terrasse,
die darf ja schon eine Weile raus,
ich habe euch das ja gerade erzählt, ich habe die Terrasse ja quasi
so katzensicher gemacht, dass sie nicht abhauen kann
und ich habe eh mehrstufige
Sicherung.
Ich habe das Netz an der Terrasse
und der Hof selber ist auch nochmal
halbwegs katzensicher.
So.
Und
seitdem die raus darf auf die Terrasse,
habe ich auch den Eindruck, ist
Chico viel besser drauf.
Also Chico ist so
planlos, die wird sich verlaufen, wenn wir
zurückfinden.
Sie ist bei mir
genauso, also ohne Mist, seitdem
Chico raus darf, die darf jetzt auch schon
raus.
Über ein Jahr darf die schon raus.
Letzten Sommer war das schon da.
Ich glaube, das haben wir sogar noch Anfang von Corona.
Die darf schon 2,5 Jahre
oder so raus. Aber seitdem die raus darf,
ist Chico viel besser
drauf, habe ich zumindest den Eindruck.
Und die mag mich mehr als vorher.
Ich glaube, also was heißt
die mag mich, die schleimt bei mir viel
mehr rum als früher, die Katz.
Ich glaube
irgendwie, dass
sie das schon kapiert hat,
dass
ich ihr das jetzt quasi so gemacht
habe, dass sie raus kann. Also
sie checkt nicht, dass ich das umgebaut habe,
dass sie raus kann, aber Chico hat
kapiert, dass ich derjenige bin,
der sie raus gelassen hat
zuerst. Und das fand sie super.
Dass ich natürlich auch die Terrasse
da soweit umgebaut habe,
dass
sie da raus kann, das weiß sie natürlich
nicht. Aber
die hat schon gecheckt, dass ich sie da jetzt
zum ersten Mal rausgelassen habe und das fand sie ganz
toll. Und seitdem schleimt
die auch viel mehr bei mir rum.
Es könnte aber auch daran liegen, dass sie dann jetzt zweieinhalb
Jahre länger da ist. Keine Ahnung.
Das ist doch so nice. Also das hat
Chico tatsächlich noch nie gemacht.
Chico beißt und kratzt mich nur, wenn
sie sie überkommt, weil sie jetzt irgendwie ganz wilde
Spielanfälle hat. Aber dann beißt die auch
nicht richtig fest, sondern
ein bisschen, also nur wenn sie es
überkommt. Also der einzige
Fehler, den man nicht machen darf, ist bei der,
wenn sie anfängt, ein bisschen zu beißen
und gerade die Hand wegzuziehen, weil dann tust
du dir weh. Wenn du die Hand da lässt,
dann passiert eigentlich gar nichts. Da muss man sich
aber auch erst mal dran gewöhnen. Weiß man ja nicht.
Ja, wenn man die Katze nicht kennt und die
Katze fängt an, in die Hand zu beißen
und du denkst dir, okay, wenn die jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr
beißt, dann tut's weh und dann blutet's.
Dann ziehst du vielleicht die Hand instinktiv
weg, aber dann ist Chico der Meinung, sie muss die Hand
jetzt fangen. Wenn du die, wenn du die Hand
einfach da lässt, ist eigentlich alles okay.
Und das ist dann auch das einzige, was meine Katze
mag, ist, wenn es beim Spielen
geht, ist entweder
so mit meiner Hand spielen oder
das einzige, was sie sonst noch mag,
ist so eine komische Angel,
wo allerdings nichts mehr dran ist, sondern nur noch
der Faden dranhängt. Aber den Faden
finden wir auch furchtbar geil.
Ja, die brauchen manchmal ein bisschen
für... Ja, das ist normal,
dass sie am Bauch
nicht gestreichelt werden wollen. Also das,
das hab ich auch jetzt, das hab ich
auch schon gelernt. Also
auch bei den Letzten schon oder schon
früher, wo ich kleiner war. Nur weil die sich
auf den Rücken legen zum Bauch streicheln,
dann heißt nicht, dass die Bauch
gestreichelt werden wollen. Das heißt
eher so eine Geste wie, ach guck mal, wie
schön entspannt ich bin.
Und die
meisten mögen das nicht, am Bauch gestreichelt zu
werden. Das ist eher so,
ich bin super entspannt. Und was man
auch nicht vergessen darf, ist, dieses
ich leg mich so seitlich hin,
ist bei Katzen auch oftmals
Verteidigungshaltung, weil
also
es gibt ja so Leute, die sagen, oh guck mal, die Katze
unterwirft sich so, weil sie so auf den Rücken
liegt. Stimmt überhaupt nicht. Das ist,
das ist Verteidigung, also
oftmals Verteidigungshaltung,
was die auch in freier Wildbahn machen,
weil sie dann eben mit den
hinter-, mit den, mit den Krallen von
den Hinterbeinen und mit den Krallen von den
von den Vorderpfoten sich verteidigen können.
Also auf den Rücken legen ist oftmals,
je nachdem, natürlich, was die Katze für
Anzeige meint, ist das auch Verteidigungshaltung.
Also nur, nur weil sich eine Katze
auf den Rücken legt, ich würde um Leben nicht an den Bauch
gehen. Also wenn du, ähm,
wenn du gekratzt
werden willst, dann, äh, geh
an den Bauch, ja. Wobei
ich ja manchmal meine Katze ein bisschen ärgere.
Ich tu dann halt so, als will ich da an den Bauch gehen und
dann, äh, kann man
ein bisschen, kann sie,
kann sie mich versuchen zu fangen.
So, gut. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Okay, Chat, was wollen wir uns als
erstes angucken? Wir haben noch eine Stunde Zeit, also
wir gucken uns, uns heute auf jeden
Fall an, das Wichtigste,
was bei der Apple-Konferenz rausgekommen
ist. Wollen wir uns vorher
gucken, warum, warum
Java a huge comeback
macht.
Java, oder auch
Java vielleicht.
Am schlimmsten finde ich ja
Javascript, wie er das immer ausspricht.
Javascript.
Okay.
War da grad die Suche reingeklitscht?
Ja. Okay.
Javascript.
Java. Ich mag die Aussprache,
ist zu geil. Also wahrscheinlich
ist sie sogar richtig.
Wie sprich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt
eine offizielle Aussprache von Java gibt.
Ich dachte, ich dachte eigentlich, dass,
ich dachte früher zumindest immer,
dass Java was mit, mit dieser Insel
zu tun hat. Allerdings
wurde ich eines Besseren belehrt,
dass Java
gar nicht wirklich was mit der Insel zu tun hat,
sondern,
dass das wohl tatsächlich
von dem Kaffee kommt.
Ja.
Und wisst
ihr, Quizfrage,
ohne zu googeln, Leute, und es gibt auch
nichts zu gewinnen, Fiveheadtest,
wisst ihr, wie der Binary
Header ist, von einem
Java Binary,
also der
FileType Header,
oder wie nennt sich das?
ELF Header, oder sowas?
In Hex. In Hex.
Der Binary Header von nem,
von nem Java Executable.
In Hex.
Ich habe gedacht,
wir haben hier irgendwelche krassen Java Kenner.
Coffee, fast.
Es ist, es ist
Kaffee Babe.
Caffee, Caffee Babe, oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Ihr wart schon,
ihr wart schon halbwegs nah dran, ja.
Oh, dürfen wir das jetzt überhaupt noch
auf Twitch noch sagen?
Weil, weil neue Guidelines und so.
Ich hab gedacht, wir haben hier
krasse Java-Hackermans.
Die wissen das.
Okay, also, Java.
It is June 5th, 2023
and you are watching the Code Report.
Java is hands down my all time
favorite programming language.
Ich wollte gerade,
ich wollte gerade schon sagen,
ich wollte gerade
schon sagen, das kauf ich ihm aber nicht ab.
watching the Code Report.
Java is hands down my all time favorite programming language.
Bis hierhin hab ich mir schon gedacht,
krasser G-Bait, aber danach, ja.
To make fun of.
Python-Developers roast it for having so much boilerplate.
C-Developers laugh at absurd class names
like Abstract Factory Manager Singleton
Service Manager Factory.
Leute,
so sehr,
so sehr das
immer gemeamt wird, die Klassennamen
von Java,
die besten Memes sind die
und die besten Witze sind die,
die recht nah an der Realität
sind und trotzdem irgendwie das ganze nochmal
auf die Spitze treiben. Also Java-Klassen,
so weit von der Realität fern
ist dieses Beispiel nicht.
Man muss aber sagen, das hat nicht nur
Java das Problem, ich hab auch
schon in .NET teilweise Klassennamen
gesehen, die sind nicht mehr feierlich.
Wobei ich in .NET tatsächlich
relativ selten sehe,
dass irgendwas Manager heißt.
Factory, ja, ist
sogar im .NET Framework öfters mal
drinne.
Singleton selber sehe ich auch äußerst
selten in Klassennamen drinne.
Aber sag mal so, in .NET fällt mir eigentlich
hauptsächlich, dass Factory manchmal vorkommt.
Und Service.
Service und Factory.
Aber das ist tatsächlich gar nicht mal
so weit weg.
Ach, du hast recht, tatsächlich, ja.
Da hab ich jetzt gar nicht dran gedacht, du hast recht.
Ja, jaja.
Aber es ist keine Manager Factory.
Ja, du hast recht. Stimmt, gibt's auch.
Ist mir grad nicht eingefallen.
Aber es ist nicht so weit weg von der Realität.
Aber es ist nicht so weit von der Realität.
...
Weil das haben die in C-Sharp auch vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit eingeführt, dass man, wobei man in C-Sharp tatsächlich das hier weglassen kann und direkt Console.WriteLine schreiben darf.
Allerdings, und da muss ich mich jetzt mal outen, GachiBuzz, ich mag das nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, aber wir gucken das Video erstmal weiter.
Also so sieht es in C-Sharp aktuell aus. Das ist erlaubt, ja, als Einstiegspunkt.
Ich muss aber sagen,
ich bin tatsächlich im Nachhinein, also ich fand das Feature, als sie das in C-Sharp eingeführt haben,
auf dem Papier ziemlich gut.
Ich habe mir nämlich gedacht, okay, das ist nice für Beispiele
und überzeugt die ganzen Python und Express, JS und sonst was Fanboys,
dass sie sich mal C-Sharp angucken, weil es jetzt auch so kurz und knackig ist.
Aber, wenn man weiß, wie C-Sharp funktioniert,
und C-Sharp das unter der Haube händelt, finde ich es tatsächlich besser,
man würde es einfach klar hinschreiben.
Weil, dadurch, dass man das so schreiben kann, suggeriert das ja irgendwie,
dass C-Sharp quasi Code außerhalb von Funktionen kann,
oder noch besser, Funktionen außerhalb von Klassen kann.
Und das stimmt beides nicht.
Was ich übrigens auch persönlich nicht verstehe,
warum in C-Sharp nicht direkt Funktionen außerhalb von Klassen kann,
sondern Funktionen außerhalb von Klassen erlaubt sind.
Auf der einen Seite, ja, ich weiß, mit Umwegen geht das natürlich,
ja, du kannst irgendwelche Lambda-Ausdrücke, Variablen zuweisen,
oder du kannst lokale Functions machen und sowas,
aber warum kann ich in C-Sharp nicht einfach schreiben, int blub.
Und das ist dann eine Funktion, die nicht zu irgendeiner Klasse gehören muss.
Oder vielleicht hätten sie dafür irgendwie einen File-Name, irgendwas,
oder irgendwas, was man direkt im Name sieht.
Also, ich weiß nicht, ob man das in C-Sharp macht,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob man das in C-Space aufruft, was auch immer.
Da gibt es sicherlich ein paar gute Sachen.
Das verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht,
warum man das in C-Sharp nicht gemacht hat schon längst,
weil sie versuchen, die letzten Sprachen,
die letzten Versionen über die Sprache immer funktionaler zu machen.
Also nicht Java, sondern C-Sharp.
Und da würde das irgendwie einfach dazu passen.
Und es geht ja auch schon über ein paar kleine Umwege,
warum nicht einfach Top-Level-Funktionen erlauben.
Das verstehe ich in C-Sharp tatsächlich nicht so ganz,
warum sie das gemacht haben.
Nachdem das nicht der Fall ist,
und ich denke, um jetzt mal zurückzukommen zu Java,
ich denke, dass sie das in Java ähnlich machen werden wie in C-Sharp,
wegen Objektorientierung.
Ja gut, aber wie gesagt, sie versuchen die Sprache deutlich funktionaler zu machen,
die letzten Versionen über.
Und sie sind selbst auch,
wenn man sich mal ihre ganzen Bilder und Interface-Geschichten ansieht,
die sie eingeführt haben,
die sind selber auch in der Standard-Library in .NET
nicht mehr so richtig krass objektorientiert unterwegs.
Wie früher.
So, und ich vermute mal,
dass Java, wenn sie sowas einführen,
das genauso machen wie C-Sharp,
nämlich, dass sie das einfach faken.
Und deswegen bin ich auch gar kein Fan mehr davon mittlerweile.
Wie gesagt, ursprünglich dachte ich mir,
das ist eine super Idee, sowas einzuführen.
Das überzeugt die ganzen Python-Fanboys,
sich mal eine ordentliche Sprache anzugucken.
Aber unter der Haube generiert das hier einfach nur für dich
eine static void main oder static int main args Methode.
Und eine Klasse drumherum.
Und das ist mir zu viel Magic unter der Haube.
Wenn es das doch eh braucht,
weil die Runtime oder was auch immer,
der Compiler oder wie auch immer,
das sonst nicht übersetzen kann.
Warum?
Lass es die Leute doch einfach hinschreiben.
Dann weißt du wenigstens, was passiert.
Weil unterm Strich sorgt das einfach nur,
für Verwirrung.
Weil du denkst,
du kannst einfach Code in eine CS-Datei schreiben
und es geht.
Es funktioniert aber gar nicht.
Es funktioniert nur bei der allerersten Datei,
weil bei der nächsten Datei sagt er,
wahrscheinlich sowas wie duplicate declaration static main.
Oder nee, der sagt was anderes.
Der sagt irgendwie top level statements,
only irgendwie in einem File oder irgendwie sowas.
Deswegen muss ich sagen,
ich fand es cool bei der Ankündigung.
Aber jetzt im Nachhinein muss ich sagen,
es war keine so gute Idee.
Und einige Sachen, die sie in C-Sharp,
die letzten Versionen eingeführt haben,
dachte ich mir, eigentlich ganz cool.
Aber der Konsistenz halber und der Logik halber,
hätte man es vielleicht lieber sein lassen sollen.
Auch die ganze Geschichte,
die sie jetzt einführt mit record struct,
class struct, ref struct
und jetzt demnächst top level constructors und sowas.
Oder nee, wie heißt das?
Class level constructors.
Da blickt doch keine Sau mehr durch.
Und du hast dann Sachen, die sehen total ähnlich aus,
aber verhalten sich im Detail anders.
Das hätte eigentlich alles nicht sein gewusst.
Also record types ist okay gewesen,
aber die ganzen anderen Dinger drumherum,
ich weiß ja nicht.
So, aber wir sind ja bei Java.
Keksoße fragt, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ich habe das nicht ganz verstanden.
Also muss ich jetzt in Zukunft nicht mehr die static void args Methode...
Ja, das hast du richtig verstanden.
Du kannst es jetzt abkürzen.
Allerdings, ich vermute,
dass sie das genauso machen werden,
wie in C-Sharp,
dass die unter der Haube exakt das gleiche generieren,
wie vorher nötig war,
nur dass du es nicht mehr schreiben musst.
Und das wird da auch für Inkonsistenzen sorgen,
weil die Leute verwirrt sind,
warum sie nur in einem File das benutzen dürfen.
Nutzt keiner.
Also in der .NET Welt ist das mittlerweile so,
gar im Standard Application Template so,
dass das benutzt wird mit top level Statements.
Go ist nicht einfach.
Go versucht möglichst widerspruchsfrei zu sein.
Okay, einfach.
Okay, wenn du das mit einfach meinst,
gebe ich dir recht.
An sich muss ich sagen,
ist Go nicht einfach,
wenn es um die,
wie soll ich sagen,
die kurz und knackige,
elegante Umsetzung von manchen Sachen geht.
Zum Beispiel,
musstest du jahrelang nested Schleifen in Go schreiben,
weil die halt gesagt haben,
nested Schleifen ist besser als irgendwie Array Filter.
Was ich mega bescheuert fand,
aber gut,
das war halt die Go-Philosophie.
Die haben gesagt,
okay,
es soll alles möglichst schön klar sein,
dass man immer sieht,
was passiert und immer nur möglichst einen Weg geben.
Wobei selbst das ja bei Go nicht so ganz stimmt.
Du hast bei Go so Sachen wie deine Error Objects.
Du hast aber trotzdem einen Panic
und du hast einen Recover von dem Panic.
Heißt das Recover in Go?
Oder war das Rust?
Bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Bring ich das durcheinander?
War das Rust?
Go, Panic, Recover?
Ja.
Also sprich,
das ist so ein Ding,
was ich bei Go auch nicht so ganz kapiert habe.
Auf der einen Seite,
ja,
hat man,
soll man Error Handling machen
über,
ja,
Return Objekte.
Allerdings auf der anderen Seite hat man Panic und Recover,
was wiederum sowas ähnliches wie ein Try-Expect ist.
Oder Try-Catch ist.
Ja, gut.
Aber insgesamt möchte Go relativ widerspruchsfrei sein
und das kriegen sie eigentlich auch ganz gut hin.
Ja, du hast zwar immer noch drei Varianten,
wie du deine Variablen anlegen kannst,
aber die haben tatsächlich sogar ihren Sinn.
Ja, du kannst ja,
du kannst ja in Go,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
ob ich aus dem Kopf hingreife,
du kannst ja in Go schreiben,
war,
blub,
blub gleich eins,
nee,
Moment, Moment,
Schwachsinn.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Go,
äh, int,
oh Gott,
ich krieg Go aus dem Kopf nicht hin.
Ich glaube,
das geht,
dann kannst du irgendwie sagen,
int,
blub
und
das geht auch
ohne
und dann kannst du so machen,
noch,
ja,
also,
ich kenne die Guidelines,
zumindest immer,
wenn ich was in Go mache,
kenne ich sie kurzzeitig.
Wann man was verwendet,
das ist auch nicht so ganz klar.
Aber,
Go,
Go versucht tatsächlich,
relativ widerspruchsfrei zu sein
und das ist,
glaube ich,
auch das,
was man in der Sprache vom Style her
mit am ehesten noch anrechnen kann.
Ich persönlich mag Go von der Syntax her nicht.
Ich habe auch schon,
wir haben sogar im Stream schon Sachen in Soap,
in Go programmiert.
Es ist nicht so,
dass man nicht Go,
Go nicht,
nicht gut programmieren könnte,
also Go ist durchaus in Ordnung.
Ich muss sagen,
ich finde die Standard Library teilweise ein bisschen,
auch wenn das eines der Punkte ist,
die immer hoch ist,
ich finde,
ich finde die Standard Library teilweise ein bisschen,
auch wenn das eines der Punkte ist,
teilweise ein bisschen, auch wenn das
eines der Punkte ist, die immer übelst hoch
gelobt wird von Go. Go hat coole Sachen
in der Standard-Library,
aber manche Sachen fehlen einfach.
Zum Beispiel wie ordentliches
Day-Time-Handling.
Die haben viele Sachen drin, die man braucht,
aber so essentielle Sachen
wie zum Beispiel ein
ordentlichen
Timestamp-Typ
haben sie nicht. Ich weiß,
es gibt Time-Delta, aber mit Time-Delta
kannst du nicht gescheit rechnen.
So, also, wo ich mir jetzt immer so denke,
ja, cool, gibt es, ah, nee, aber das, was ich machen will,
geht so ohne weiteres nicht. Da muss ich selbst
irgendwas basteln.
Das hat mich teilweise manchmal ein bisschen
an C++ erinnert.
Aber insgesamt ist Go tatsächlich
ganz angenehm, aber trotzdem muss ich sagen,
ich persönlich mag die Go-Syntax
nicht.
Was ich auch ein bisschen nervig finde bei Go,
was ich aber auch
verstehen kann, dass es irgendwie Sinn macht,
aber ich mag es nicht, ist diese
erzwungene
Syntax-Check-In-Geschichte,
ja, dass du nicht
kompilieren kannst, wenn was auskommentiert
ist. Dass das nicht kompiliert,
wenn du die If-Else-Klammern
falsch
gesetzt hast oder falsch gesetzt
hast in Go
Logik.
Also,
das ist was, was mich bei,
dass du Imports nicht einfach
mal drin stehen lassen kannst,
wenn du mal kurz halt was auskommentieren
musst und sowas.
Also,
einiges an Go nervt.
Vieles fangen IDEs ab, weil die mitdenken,
aber es gibt schon ein paar Sachen,
die nerven. Ich kann bei den
meisten Sachen nachvollziehen, warum man
sich dafür entschieden hat, aber trotzdem
ist Go nicht so richtig
mein Fall. Ne, das
glaube ich nicht, dass es ein Error gibt, wenn man das
nicht macht. Du kannst sicherlich immer noch
Static Void mal hinschreiben, allein schon
die 100 Jahre Java Legacy Code.
Da haben sie aber viel
zu tun, zu C++
aufzuschließen.
Also, ich glaube, im Thema Bullshit
schließt keiner jemals wieder
zu C++ auf. Ich glaube,
die einzigen, die
die Bullshiterei von C++ noch
übertreffen können, sind irgendwelche so
esoterischen Programmiersprachen,
die explizit erschaffen wurden, um kacke
zu sein. C++ ist die
einzige Programmiersprache,
die es schafft,
scheiße zu sein, obwohl man
eigentlich nicht scheiße sein als Ziel hat.
Das schaffen sonst nur so
Sprachen wie Brainfuck oder Whitespace
oder sowas. Nein, selbst
PHP ist nicht kacke. PHP ist
mittlerweile sogar ganz okay, gerade
mit irgendeinem halbwegs gescheiten Framework.
Aber C++
ist die einzige ernst
gemeinte Programmiersprache,
die es schafft, sich über die letzten
Jahre noch wirrer
und noch widersprüchlicher
immer wieder zu gestalten.
Ja, also Werbung für hasserfüllten
C++-Content darf ich nicht machen.
C++ ist auch gut, wenn man
kein Legacy-Code hat.
Hast du dir mal angeguckt,
die Hilfe-Seite von
ähm, Enable-
Moment.
Pass mal auf, wo wir dabei sind, C++.
So.
Okay.
Und jetzt erzähl mir nochmal, dass modernes C++
gut ist.
Ich gebe zu,
das ist ein bisschen fieses Beispiel,
weil Templates
aber schon mal abfuck an sich sind,
Templates sind
quasi
eines der geilsten und beschissensten
Features von C++ zugleich.
Ja, ne? Also allein schon,
allein schon, dass sowas in der Standard-Library
drin ist und du brauchst, weißt du schon mal,
es ist komplett lost.
Standard is trivially destructible.
Da weißt du echt Bescheid, oder?
Da weißt du diese nicht mehr ganz nicht.
Und vor allem das hier, Alter, das versteht...
Na gut.
Aber, jetzt mal, jetzt mal, ähm,
wie gesagt, also C++-Templates sind eines der geilsten
und beschissensten Features in einem.
Was, was dieses Beispiel,
weil, wie gesagt, wie, wie gesagt,
eigentlich ist es ein bisschen ein unfaires Beispiel,
sich jetzt ausgerechnet so ein komisches Ding
da rauszupicken, um zu sagen, wie kacke C++ ist.
Aber das ist sinnbildlich für C++
und wie sich das die letzten Jahre überentwickelt.
Aber, um das jetzt nochmal zu unterstreichen,
wie bescheuert das eigentlich ist.
Wir sind hier in quasi in der C++-Reference.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das die offiziellen Docs sind oder nicht.
Aber ich glaube, das ist somit das offiziellste an Docs,
was es gibt für C++.
So.
Also, man muss sich mal überlegen.
Irgendjemand hat Doku geschrieben
für dieses Feature, was wir hier sehen.
Und hat sich gedacht,
das hier ist das beste Beispiel, was ihm einfällt,
in der besten Formatierung.
Also, sprich, das ist das Beste, was man machen kann in C++.
Und das ist das Beste, was man machen kann in C++.
Um dieses Feature zu demonstrieren.
Das sollte, glaube ich, alles über die Syntax-Erweiterung
und Sache dieser Sprache aus sein.
Also, irgendjemand dachte, das ist das beste Beispiel,
was wir präsentieren können für dieses Feature.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es das auch.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal gelogen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wirklich das beste Beispiel für dieses Feature.
Aber es ist halt komplett unreadable.
Siehst du, Inside?
Sogar jemand, der keine Ahnung hat,
keine Ahnung davon hat, erkennt...
Gut, ich kann nicht sagen...
Ich meine, what the...
Was, was, bitteschön, ist das hier schon einmal?
Das ist das...
Oder?
Es kann das sein?
Okay, okay.
Alter, what the fuck?
Okay, es ist enabled if...
Wenn es nicht...
Wenn es nicht trivially destructible of T ist,
also irgendein generic type,
und wenn es...
wenn es...
eine Klasse ist,
dann ist es...
Warum auch immer das hier jetzt an der Stelle
geschweifte Klammern, geschweifte Klammern auf und zu haben muss,
an der Stelle?
Ich dachte, es ist eine Typdefinition und...
Was auch immer.
Es ist C++, muss man nicht hinterfragen.
Oder das...
What the fuck?
Ja, das hatten wir schon mal.
Das musste jetzt sein, weil jemand gesagt hat,
C++, modernes C++ ist geil.
Da musste ich gleich mal sagen,
nein, modernes C++ ist nicht zwangsläufig geil.
Man kann sicherlich auch schön programmieren
in C++.
Das will ich gar nicht bestreiten.
Aber das Gremium,
das C++-Standard-Konsortium,
Gremium, wie auch immer die heißen,
sind nicht sonderlich bemüht,
die Sprache besser lesbar
und konsistenter zu machen,
die letzten Versionen über.
Die führen lieber 500 neue
Sonderzeichen ein.
An das Trinken erinnern.
Okay, okay, ist gut, Leute.
Ich hab gedrungen.
Ja, dann wird das nicht funktionieren.
Aber auch an,
in Main brauchst du Annotations.
Tomux, danke für den Sub.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich seh's ja auch so.
Ich verstehe oftmals, warum
die das in Go gemacht haben.
Deswegen,
es trägt aber auch mit so bei,
dass ich Go jetzt nicht so angenehm empfinde.
Max kann doch auch Python in Go einbetten, oder?
Man kann aber, ähm, nicht Max,
ja, Max könnte das vielleicht auch.
Man kann doch auch Python in Go einbetten.
Also ich will jetzt nicht ausschließen,
dass irgendwelche verrückten Leute auf GitHub
sowas gebaut haben.
Ähm, dass du quasi Go in Python templaten kannst,
was dann während dem Compile-Vorgang
on the fly Go generiert und bestimmt, bestimmt.
Ähm, aber so bekannt wäre mir das jetzt erstmal nicht.
Was du machen kannst, ist,
du kannst, ähm, auf jeden Fall aus Python heraus
Go-Sachen aufrufen.
Allerdings auch nur, wenn du die als C-Funktionen
exportierst.
Und C-Go ist auch so ein Ding,
was nicht viel Liebe bekommt von den,
von den, äh, Go-Entwicklern.
Umgedreht,
dass du Python aus Go heraus aufrufst,
wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
wie man das gescheit machen soll.
Weil zumindest die Standard-Go-Sachen
sind ja keine Binaries
mit, mit, mit irgendwelchen, ähm,
C-kompatiblen Interface,
also C-kompatiblen Funktionsdefinitionen,
die man callen kann,
sondern irgendwas,
was erstmal da gejittet werden muss
von, von irgendeiner Python-Runtime.
Wenn du das Python-Zeug vielleicht im Vorfeld
äh, kompilierst mit irgendeinem der Python-Compiler
und dann irgendwelche C-Interfaces
da exportieren kannst,
dann mag es vielleicht funktionieren.
Aber da kenne ich,
das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert tatsächlich,
das irgendwie miteinander zu verheiraten.
Ja, aber trotzdem gefällt mir die Syntax nicht.
Warum kopierst du eigentlich immer einzelne Buchstaben
in die Zwischenablage?
Meinst du sowas hier?
Weiß nicht, weil ich mir das so ange...
Also, eigentlich mache ich es ja hauptsächlich so.
Das ist so eine Angewohnheit von mir.
Wenn du es, wenn du es genau wissen willst,
musst du Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat eingeben.
Da gibt es eine Erklärung für.
Das ist doch CheapAid.
Damit fangen wir jetzt nicht an.
Ich habe mich lange genug darüber ausgelassen,
sonst rante ich jetzt die nächsten 15 Minuten
über C++.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Also ich muss, ich, ich muss sagen,
ich habe mich mit, die letzten Jahre über
tatsächlich mit relativ vielen Sprachen beschäftigt.
Wir haben uns ja auch hier im Stream...
Ich glaube, Chat, ich glaube, dass eines der wenigen Sachen,
die wir noch nicht im Stream gemacht haben,
ist Ruby on Rails.
Kann das sein?
Wobei ich früher...
Ich kriege es, glaube ich, nicht mehr gebacken gescheit.
Aber ich habe früher sehr viel in Ruby gemacht.
Also wirklich viel.
Immer alles, was es zu Skripten gab,
habe ich in Ruby gemacht.
Und ich habe auch die ein oder andere Rails-Geschichte gemacht.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das interessiert,
ob wir irgendwann mal was Kleines in Ruby on Rails machen sollen.
Ich glaube, ich, ich habe, ich glaube schon wieder,
fast alles vergessen.
Ruby.
Ja, äh, PHP, ähm, ich...
Ah ja, Leute, das ist tatsächlich was Gutes.
Das müssen wir mal machen.
Äh, Stream-Themen.
Ich wollte mir seit Ewigkeiten
schon mal wieder Laravel mit PHP angucken.
Ich habe mit Laravel mal was gemacht, vor Jahren.
Als ich...
Hat irgendjemand zufällig damals auf meinem Battlefield 4 Server gespielt
und, ähm, die, die Server-Signatur verwendet,
wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ähm, ich hatte damals für mein Battlefield 4 Server
eine Statistik-Signatur gebaut, die man sich generieren konnte.
So mit, äh, dieser Server, so viel Kills und, und sowas in der Richtung.
Äh, so viel Kills, so eine KD und sowas.
Ich habe quasi so einen Mini-Battle-Lock gebaut,
nur für meinen Server.
Damals in Battlefield 4.
Und das habe ich in PHP und Laravel gemacht.
Äh, äh, der Grund war, der Grund war relativ einfach.
Es gab irgendwie ein super billiges Web,
irgendwie ein super billiges Web-Hosting mit MySQL und PHP.
Und der Battlefield-Server brauchte selbst für Statistiken zu locken,
schon die MySQL-Datenbank.
Und die war schon bei dem Anbieter.
Und deswegen hat sich das einfach angeboten.
C Sharp ist Poggers.
Hatte heute auch jemand die mündliche Abschlussprüfung?
Das gebe ich mal weiter, Chat.
Also ich nicht.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt das Video weiter.
Ich meine, wir haben es ernsthaft geschafft,
in einer halben Stunde, glaube ich, eine Minute Video zu gucken.
Das musst du erst mal hinkriegen.
Okay, wir sind verstehen geblieben.
Ich spule mal kurz ein paar Sekunden zurück.
Ja, und jetzt hast du es wie in C Sharp.
Da kann man sich jetzt,
tatsächlich, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Ich weiß, der Python-Way und sowas in der Richtung,
da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das ohne Namespaces und alles wirklich so das Geilste ist.
Und wenn wir es zur Prüfung renamen, bekommen wir dann eine perfekte Sprache.
C Sharp hat in 2020 Top-Level-Statements vorgelegt.
Ja.
Und vielleicht in noch 10 Jahren wird Java auch da sein.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich finde es im Nachhinein,
betrachten Sie C Sharp, auch keine gute Entscheidung.
Bevor Sie zu begeistert werden,
diese Feature ist primär dafür geschaffen,
Java für Anfänger zu lernen.
Die echte Boilerplatte geht nicht woanders.
Außerdem ist Java primär in Enterprise verwendet,
was sehr langsam ist, neue Features zu erwerben.
Es gibt viele mission-kritische Applikationen,
die noch Java 8 anbieten.
Und es könnte Jahre oder sogar Jahrzehnte dauern,
bevor diese neuen Features erwerbt werden.
Aber Java 21 hat auch andere coole Updates,
wie Structured Concurrency,
Was?
Structured Concurrency?
Äh, was bin ich sehend? Irgendwas?
Irgendwelche Java Generics?
Future T?
Äh, ist Future T?
Ist Future T sowas wie Task in C Sharp?
Wahrscheinlich.
Sieht ein bisschen so aus.
Ähm...
Chat?
Warum haben die zwei Return Types?
Warum haben die ein T als Return Type
und ein List of Future T?
Da hört mein Java-Verständnis jetzt schon auf,
warum die zwei Return Types haben.
Irgendwelche Java Magic, keine Ahnung.
Das ist Java Exception Zeug,
dass man das angeben muss, was das werfen kann.
Okay, das...
Ähm...
Und der Rest ist erstaunlich schwierig zu lesen,
für das, dass sie das irgendwie erst jetzt letztens designed haben.
Ja, okay.
...while treating them as a single unit of work.
But another thing you might find kind of crazy about Java
is that it doesn't natively support string interpolation,
which means you need to concatenate a bunch of strings together
like you're in Kindergarten,
or use string.format, which is also kind of annoying.
But in Java 21 we have a new string templates feature,
which is a new kind of expression
that allows you to insert values directly...
Man muss da nicht wirklich str. davor schreiben, oder?
Das ist ja die hässlichste Syntax,
die ich, glaube ich, in allen Sprachen je gesehen habe,
was String Interpolation angeht.
Und...
Und warum muss ich...
Warum muss ich ein Backslash machen
vor dem eigentlichen Escape?
Das ist ja...
Das haben...
Das ist...
Das sieht doch nicht wirklich so aus, oder?
Also, ähm...
String Format geht doch voll klar.
Weißt du, was das bisschen blöde an String Format ist?
Dass es einfach so doppelt und dreifach ist.
Ich meine, du musst hier den Text eingeben mit den Lücken,
du brauchst hier quasi Platzhalter,
und dann hinten musst du die in der richtigen Reihenfolge einsetzen.
Warum kannst du die nicht einfach hier einsetzen,
an der Stelle, wo du das haben willst?
Das ist ja...
Also, ich...
Ich find ordentliche String Interpolation
viel, viel besser, als so ein Formatding.
Das muss ich mal kurz angucken.
Ja, für allen 20 String Templates,
da brauche ich mal ein Beispiel von...
String Templates Preview.
Ja, da gibt's da vielleicht auch mal ein kurzes Exkampel.
Ja.
Harness the Power of String Templates.
Okay, ja, so...
Okay, ja, so macht man's nicht.
Äh, das ist
JavaScript-Syntax?
Haben die das jetzt übernommen aus JavaScript?
Das ist original, die JavaScript-Template-Syntax.
...circle to where
Java is now looking more like JavaScript
...feature, which is a new kind of expression
that allows you to insert values
directly into strings. We've come full circle
to where Java is now looking more like
JavaScript, and JavaScript is looking more
like Java. And I even noticed that Java
recently updated their website, so now it
...was?
Die Java-Download-Seite sieht mal
halbwegs modern aus.
Da würde ich gleich einen Phishing-Angriff
vermuten, wenn ich auf die neue Java-Seite komme.
Tatsächlich!
Die sieht jetzt
auch irgendwie kacke aus,
aber
aber wenigstens nicht mal mit 2005
oder...
...only looks 10 years out of date instead of 20.
This is a big strategic move that has caused
Oracle stock to almost double over the last year.
The big question, though, is with all these
awesome new features, should you learn Java
in 2023? When it comes to working as a
programmer, you should choose a field that's
well-paid, interesting, and legal.
But the reality is that you can only choose two of these.
Java is well-paid and legal,
but not very interesting. When looking at the
syntax alone, Java is pretty ugly.
If I wanted to write code for the JVM for fun,
I'd much rather use a language like Kotlin or something.
Ja, ich auch. Also wenn
ich... Das wollte ich mir übrigens auch mal
mit euch irgendwann zusammen angucken, Kotlin.
Wenn ich jemals was...
für die Java-Runtime baue, dann
auf jeden Fall nicht in Java selbst.
Scala. That being said... Und Scala
benutze ich auch nicht, weil es hat mir zu viele Klammern.
...Java is still a powerhouse language
when it comes to enterprise software. It's used
extensively at companies like Twitter and Google
because it's a very well-balanced language.
It's performant enough for most things, it's
relatively easy to use, and most importantly
has a huge ecosystem of stable
libraries and frameworks. A few days ago I ran
a poll for the best programming language of all time.
Da fehlen vielleicht noch ein paar
Optionen.
Da hat nicht allen Ernstes
C++ gewonnen, oder?
Die wollen mir nicht einzeln erzählen, dass C++
das ist doch G-Bait, oder?
Und JavaScript ist sicherlich
auch nicht die beste Sprache aller Zeiten.
Aber JavaScript hat sich
gemacht die letzten Jahre über.
Im Gegensatz zu C++.
Also man könnte sagen,
JavaScript hat die umgekehrte Entwicklung von
C++ gemacht.
Die JavaScript-Standard-Leute
die haben die letzten 15 Jahre
über aus einer ziemlich ekligen
Sprache eine echt
ganz gut benutzbare
und auch
durchdachte Sprache gemacht
mit den neuen Features.
Und auch den Standard-Library-Erweiterungen
und sowas, schon ganz okay.
Also die haben ihre Sprache eindeutig
deutlich verbessert die letzten
15 Jahre über.
C++ hat auch einige Punkte
verbessert, so ist es nicht.
Aber ganz, ganz viel Scheiße draufgepackt.
Also insofern,
ähm,
also hier, in dieser Abstimmung
würde ich sagen, wenn es um Sprachen geht,
in denen ich gerne programmiere,
würde ich sagen, tatsächlich,
JavaScript auf Platz 1,
Python auf Platz 2,
ja, und C++ und Java ist mir egal.
Und Java kam am Ende.
Aber jetzt, dass wir keine
stetigen Void-Main-String-Args mehr brauchen,
denke ich, dass es den Top-Spot wieder erneuert.
Und mit dem gesagt,
möchte ich mich offiziell
von making fun of Java
von making fun of Java.
Aber lasst uns diese Java-Memes zusammen
noch einmal genießen.
Wie dieses hier, das erklärt,
wie objektorientierte Design-Pattern
oft unnötig und
counterproduktiv sind, wenn man
einfach nur einfache Variablen
und Funktionen benutzen könnte.
Dieses nächste Meme ist ein guter,
aber ihr würdet es nicht bekommen,
also werde ich es nicht versuchen,
es zu erklären.
Wenn ihr Windows möchtet,
könnt ihr Java möchtet,
weil es euch liebt,
störende Updates zu machen.
Und als du mehr Erfahrung
als Programmierer erhältst,
wirst du schlussendlich herausfinden,
dass alles nicht ein Objekt ist,
weil diese Objekte sich öffnen
und dein RAM zerstören.
Und letztlich ist es wichtig,
zu erkennen, dass nicht jeder Meme
ein Lüge ist.
Viele davon sind ein legitimer
Schrei für Hilfe.
Dies war der Code-Report.
Danke fürs Zuschauen
und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Okay, dann erzähle ich es euch jetzt schnell.
Also, hatten wir schon...
Nein, hatten wir noch nicht.
Also, heute hatten wir eine lustige Diskussion.
Nein, das hat nichts mit C++,
das hat was mit Cloud-Geschichten zu tun.
Heute haben wir eine lustige Diskussion.
Und zwar, vielleicht kennt ihr es von anderen
oder vielleicht kennt ihr es auch
von eurem Arbeitgeber,
wenn neue Systeme gebaut werden
oder Services, nennen wir mal Services.
Wenn neue Systeme gebaut werden,
wenn neue Services gebaut werden,
da wird das ja nicht meistens
nur einmal hingestellt
und läuft dann da produktiv drauf
und das war's.
Also, die meisten haben zumindest mal
irgendwie sowas wie eine Testumgebung
oder irgendein Test-Environment,
um zu gucken, ob irgendwelche neuen Versionen
was kaputt machen.
Also, sagen wir mal,
ein Test-Environment und ein Live-Environment,
das haben wahrscheinlich die meisten,
die ernsthaft irgendwelche Services betreiben.
In der Regel haben die meisten
sogar noch ein Entwicklungs-Environment,
ein Test-Environment und ein Live-Environment.
Manche haben auch noch mehr.
Ist aber auch jetzt egal.
Also, ich denke, dass man so einen Staging hat,
quasi in Form von Entwicklungsumgebung,
dann sowas wie Test-Abnahme-Umgebung,
dann Live-Produktionsumgebung.
Mein Beileid.
Egal, ihr macht einfach keine Fehler.
Und wenn man keine Fehler macht,
dann kann man auch immer alles direkt in den Brot hauen.
Das ist auch easy.
Spart vor allem Geld.
So, also ich glaube, das können sich,
das können sich einige durchaus vorstellen,
dass es sinnvoll ist, so drei Umgebungen zu haben.
So, und jetzt für neues Projekt hatten wir heute die Diskussion.
Also es gibt aktuell eine Entwicklungsumgebung
und eine Test-Umgebung.
Und dann später soll es eine Live-Umgebung geben.
So, und heute hat man sich überlegt,
okay, man braucht ja quasi,
man braucht eine Test-Umgebung,
man braucht eine Entwicklungsumgebung
und man braucht noch so eine,
wir wollen neue Versionen testen, Umgebung.
So, und jetzt sind sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
ey, warum sollen wir eigentlich
da drei Kubernetes-Cluster hinstellen bei Google,
wenn man doch auch alles in unterschiedliche Namespaces machen kann,
in einen Kubernetes-Cluster?
Und da wollte ich mal zu bedenken geben,
also das heißt aber auch, wenn ein Cluster weg ist,
ist alles weg.
Also das heißt, es kann niemand mehr testen,
es kann niemand mehr gescheit entwickeln,
es kann keiner mehr neue Versionen,
weil der Cluster ist ja weg.
Ja, so, und das Argument dafür,
warum man keine eigenen Cluster
für die unterschiedliche Umgebung haben wollte,
sondern das alles einfach nur über Namespaces trennen will in Kubernetes,
war, und jetzt haltet euch fest,
ratet mal, ratet mal, was könnte das sein?
Ich meine, ihr wisst es wahrscheinlich eh schon.
Spart, spart Geld, spart Geld.
Und, spart Geld, auch wenn es nicht so richtig ernst gemeint war,
habe ich den Eindruck gehabt.
Spart Geld, und daraufhin habe ich mal gefragt,
aber sagt mal, so unser Entwicklungskubernetes-Cluster,
ja, der kostet 120 Euro im Monat.
Das ist die allerkleinste Ausführung.
Ich meine, wir sind eine Bank mit Milliarden,
jucken uns 120 Euro für einen Kubernetes-Cluster im Monat.
Und, ich meine, wir sind eine Bank mit Milliarden, jucken uns 120 Euro für einen Kubernetes-Cluster im Monat.
im Monat, wirklich?
Da mussten
auch alle mal eine Runde
kecken.
Und ich hoffe,
ich hoffe, dass sie das jetzt wieder verworfen
haben und haben einfach
und machen einfach für jede
Umgebung den Cluster, Mann.
Vielleicht
ist das zu billig. Vielleicht müsste das
mindestens 5000 Euro kosten. Ja, dann
ist es dann, dann denkt man, okay,
das ist es wert. Ja, weiß nicht.
Ich meine, ernsthaft,
allein schon die Diskussion,
sollen wir 120, ach ja,
und dann kam gleich der Nächste
um die Ecke und meinte, ja,
dann können wir doch einfach,
dann können wir doch auch einfach nur noch
eine Cloud-SQL-Datenbank hinstellen
und dort verschiedene Datenbanken
drin anlegen. Und ich bin so,
Alter, das kostet, keine Ahnung,
das kostet 25 Euro im Monat
oder so. Das Storage
ist ja das Teure, unterm Strich.
Jetzt stellt euch mal nicht so
an, Mann, 150 Euro im
Monat für eine Testdatenbank und
ein Test-Kubernetes-Cluster, Mensch.
150 Euro, das wird doch so
ein Milliardenunternehmen
irgendwie locker haben noch, oder?
Und ich hab dann als Beispiel,
ich hab dann als Beispiel gebracht,
also, ich handhabe
das ja immer so.
Wenn wir über Zahlen
reden, die ich normalerweise
für mich privat,
ohne mir es lange zu überlegen,
bezahlen würde für ein Projekt,
dann kann es eigentlich für eine
Versicherung nicht so weit her
sein. Oder mussten
sie mir tatsächlich sogar irgendwie recht geben.
Ich bin jetzt nicht scharf drauf,
120 Euro im Monat für ein Kubernetes-Cluster
privat auszugeben. Aber wenn ich
irgendwas hätte, was ich laufen lassen will,
also, ich würde es ausgeben
und ich würde es ausgeben können, da sollte
doch schon genug Indiz dafür sein,
dass man das als
Milliardenversicherung auch
ausgeben kann.
Ja, ich glaube aber, das hat
sich insoweit erledigt. Ich glaube, wir machen
es schon.
Schlicht und ergreifend.
Cluster, ein Cluster für jede
Umgebung. Also, ganz im Ernst,
dass da überhaupt drüber diskutiert
wurde, fand ich lustig, irgendwie.
Ich meine, the fuck, die machen
Millionen und Milliarden, die machen Geld
ohne Ende. Aber dann überlegen
sie sich, ob 120 Euro Kubernetes-Cluster
irgendwie Probleme macht.
Wer stellt das in Frage?
Gar nicht nur einer, das war so eine
allgemeine Frage.
Ein paar Leute waren der Meinung,
ja, kann man, sollte man so machen
und ich habe halt die
Ansicht vertreten, lasst
uns das nicht machen mit Namespaces.
Einfach jede Umgebung,
jedes Environment oder
jedes Environment, was wir brauchen,
bekommt ein eigenes
Environment, was besteht aus
eigenem Google-Projekt, eigenem
Cluster, eigener Testdatenbank,
was auch immer.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wären
das jetzt mega viele Sachen.
Du brauchst eine Testing-Umgebung,
du brauchst
eine, du brauchst irgendeine
Entwicklungsumgebung
und du brauchst irgendwie eine Live-Umgebung
und wenn man dann noch, und wenn man
dann vielleicht nochmal für andere Zwecke
noch
zwei, drei andere braucht, die zum größten Teil
auch nur temporär sind, ist das kein
Problem.
Ich meine ganz im Ernst, selbst
wenn alle Umgebungen, mal die
Produktion ausgenommen, zusammen
8000 Euro im Monat kosten
würden, selbst danach,
sollte realistisch betrachtet nicht
kein Hahn krähen.
Die machen Millionen!
Also jetzt mal ernsthaft!
C++-Devs, when they see words instead
Ja ne, das
geht natürlich nicht.
Die haben eindeutig, Spitze-Klammer auf und zu vergessen,
kein echter C++-Programmer.
Ja.
Also das wollte ich heute nur mal zum Besten geben.
Da seht
ihr mal, was auch
im
Business-Enterprise-Umfeld so diskutiert
wird, wo man sich echt fragt
so, macht's das jetzt wirklich
fett, 120 Euro oder
nicht? Das bringt
dir nicht so wirklich was in dem Fall.
Du hast schon recht, also
gerade was so, wir müssen
mal schnell was testen. Ja,
da ist Minikube oder sowas natürlich toll,
aber
ein lokaler Kubernetes-Cluster
bringt dir höchstens was, wenn du
so Container starten, stoppen und
testen willst, was da drin läuft. Wenn du
das gesamte System,
drumherum testen willst, bringt's dir nix,
weil du brauchst,
also du willst ja nicht nur deine Software alleine
testen, du willst ja auch testen, klappt
dein Terraform-Aufbau,
klappt das automatische
Rolling-Update und solche
Geschichten und das, nachdem alles
ziemlich eng verzahnt ist
mit den Services,
die Google Cloud bereitstellt,
macht es eigentlich keinen Sinn, in lokalen
Kubernetes-Cluster für solche Tests
aufzubauen,
sondern es sollte schon ein
Google-Kubernetes-Cluster, ein
GKI-Cluster sein.
Was ja auch nicht schlimm ist, ich mein, es kostet
120 Euro im Monat, jetzt
irgendwann
muss man sich nicht so anstellen.
Ich habe, was,
ich habe in der Arbeit
gerade das Vergnügen,
mich mit den BSI-Anforderungen
für Kubernetes auseinanderzuhalten. Der Vorschlag,
alles in einem Cluster zu betreiben, würde
gefühlt gegen die Hälfte davon verstoßen.
Ja, ich würde prinzipiell auch nicht alles
in einem Cluster betreiben. Allein,
schon aus dem Gesichtspunkt, wenn ein Cluster
mal nicht da ist, ist alles weg.
Und ich mein, es
verkraftet auch nicht,
jede Anwendung
gleich gut einen Rolling-Update.
Musst du dir schon ein bisschen Gedanken
zumachen. Also, es ist eigentlich nicht
sinnvoll. Ja, und was
man nicht vergessen darf, man darf ja auch nicht vergessen,
dass es
Anwenderfehler geben kann, oder Adminfehler.
Das ist auch ein Beispiel,
weil ich bei sowas immer mal ganz gerne bringe.
Es wird nämlich immer nur so getan,
dass der einzige Grund, dass
was kaputt gehen kann, ist,
dass Hardware kaputt geht, Google Scheiße
baut, oder Software kaputt ist.
Nee, nee. Es kann auch ganz normale Adminfehler
geben.
Also, man kann auch aus Versehen mal irgendwie
Kacke bauen,
und wenn man das halt gegen irgendeine Testing
und Entwicklungsumgebung macht, ist das nicht schlimm.
Aber wenn man alles auf einem Cluster
laufen hat, ist es vielleicht halt
doch schlimm, weil dann läuft halt auch
mal was Wichtiges nicht.
Also,
zumindest, zumindest einen
Live-Cluster und einen
Bastel-Cluster sollte man haben. Das sollte jeder
haben. Auf dem Bastel-Cluster
kann man meinetwegen, wenn man unbedingt
so scharf drauf ist,
in unterschiedlichen Namespaces
Entwicklung und Testing-Sachen laufen lassen.
Wobei ich auch das nicht sagen würde.
Eigentlich sollte Entwicklung
den eigenen Cluster kriegen, Testing den eigenen
Cluster kriegen, und die Live-Umgebung
den eigenen Cluster kriegen.
Weil man, wie gesagt, man darf Adminfehler
auch nicht unterschätzen. Man baut
auch mal Scheiße. Man verklickt sich auch mal
im Webinterface. Man gibt auch mal
irgendwo Mist ein. Ja, man
copy-pastet auch mal das Falsche rein.
Das kann schon mal passieren,
dass man da Mist baut.
Was gar nicht, der Admin muss da gar nicht
unfähig sein. Es passiert immer mal irgendeinen Mist.
Also, aus dem Gesichtspunkt ist das sinnvoll.
Näh, das
finde ich nicht so schlimm. Ich finde es gut,
ganz ehrlich, ich finde es gut, dass sowas vorgeschlagen
wird. Ich finde es immer gut,
wenn die Leute bei solchen Meetings
frei sagen können,
was sie für Ideen haben.
Man muss die ja am Ende nicht machen.
Wenn man dann
darauf, weil ansonsten traut sich
keiner mehr was zu sagen.
Wenn einer mal ein bisschen was
sagt, ein bisschen was, sagen wir mal in Anführungsstrichen
Blödes sagt, und man
regt sich dann gleich drüber auf, so nach dem Motto,
er soll doch lieber die Klappe halten,
dann sagt er das nächste Mal nichts mehr. Und da wäre es
vielleicht sinnvoll gewesen. Also, ich finde es immer
gut, wenn in solchen Runden jeder einfach sagen
kann, was ihm so in den Kopf kommt,
an Ideen und Vorschlägen.
Man muss es ja nicht machen am Ende.
Und ich hoffe auch nicht, dass wir es machen.
Ja, das ist ein weiterer Punkt, warum ich das
da hast du recht, das ist ein weiterer
Punkt, warum ich die Dev-Umgebung nicht lokal
mit Minikube oder besser gesagt mit Minikube
ähnlich, mit irgendeinem lokalen
Kubernetes-Täusch bauen würde und das andere in der
Google-Cloud laufen. Natürlich,
möglichst gleich, man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Also, wenn man irgendwie
einen 16-Node-Cluster in Produktion
hat, macht es ja überhaupt kein Problem, nur einen
3-Node-Cluster in Entwicklung zu benutzen.
Aber das ist ja das Schöne an der ganzen
Kubernetes- und Container-Geschichte,
dass das nochmal
so eine Zwischenabstraktionsebene
ist, dass du dich eigentlich
darauf verlassen kannst, dass alles, was da
drinnen läuft, für die Anwendung
da drinnen, dass dann kein großer Unterschied
mehr ist.
DNS-Namen sind abstrahiert,
Container von der Sache
unten drunter abstrahiert, also das ist dann
ganz gut. Da kannst du auch ein Cluster
unterschiedlich aufbauen, dann ist das für die
Anwendung da drinnen eigentlich fast egal, ob das
ein 16-Node-Cluster oder ein 3-Node-Cluster
ist. Gleiches Bad-Getime,
ja. Ja klar, natürlich,
kannst du ja so sagen, du findest das eine blöde
Idee, das ist schon, aber ich würde
dir nicht gleich sagen, so nach dem Motto,
du hast dich selber disqualifiziert und so,
dann haben die Leute das nächste Mal
keinen Bock, was zu sagen. Und das ist
tatsächlich was, was ich bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber
wirklich gut finde und auch
mit den Leuten, also auch bei mir im Team, womit
ich jetzt schon zusammengearbeitet habe, aber gerade übergreifend
im Projekt, da funktioniert
das tatsächlich ganz gut.
Also, da ist keiner da,
bisher zumindest noch nicht, keiner,
der sich bisher auf den Schlips getreten gefühlt hat,
wenn man was gesagt hat, aber umgedreht
geben die Leute sich auch Mühe,
wenn sie der Meinung sind, dass man selbst
Mist erzählt, das so zu verpacken,
dass das nicht zu negativ ankommt. Das finde ich
eigentlich ganz gut. Ja, also
die geben sich alle Mühe, dass man gut miteinander
zusammenarbeiten kann, was ich
wirklich als
sehr angenehmen
Vorteil empfinde, versus
bei meinem
alten
Arbeitgeber. Da waren ein paar Leute
dabei, die
haben quasi in den Meetings nur drauf
gewartet, um an der passenden Stelle
was zu sagen, um irgendjemanden
zu ärgern. Und das ist halt bescheuert.
Wo ich mir immer
gedacht habe, hättest du denen das
vorher gefragt, dann hättest
du das jetzt nicht absehen, also
muss ich anders sagen, also mal
angenommen, also wir hatten beim alten Arbeitgeber
hatten wir Leute, die haben quasi gewartet,
bis irgendein Status-Meeting ist
und sie wussten im
Vorfeld schon, dass irgendwas nicht so dolle ist
und
anstatt, dass die im Vorfeld mal gefragt
hätten, so nach dem Motto, warum
habt ihr das so gemacht, oder
was ist, irgendwie was
mal gefragt, haben die dann in dem Meeting
drauf gewartet, um zu sagen,
ah, ich sehe, Punkt XY wurde
immer noch nicht erledigt, so.
Ja, und das hat mich immer wahnsinnig
aufgeregt, dass
was für Kackspasten wir da hatten,
ey, das waren teilweise so
nervige Leute am Start,
das hat mich so abgefuckt,
also beim alten Arbeitgeber, da waren
so richtig nervige Leute dabei,
wo ich mir gedacht habe, die haben doch nur
drauf gewartet, in dem Meeting,
dass sie jetzt an der Stelle was sagen
konnten, wovon sie wussten,
die wussten im Vorfeld, dass es Kacke
ist, und die haben sich das explizit
aufgehoben für das Meeting, um das
anzusprechen, dass es Kacke ist.
Office-Politics, ja, klar,
ist es.
Nee, das gar nicht mal so sehr,
das hätte mich ja gar nicht gestört, da sind ja
so organisatorische Sachen,
ja, also, machen wir mal
irgendein, irgendein bisschen konstruiertes
Beispiel, ja,
also, mal angenommen,
man braucht irgendwie
Zertifikate für irgendeine neue Domain,
so, und
man hat aus irgendwelchen Gründen
zwei Wochen Verzug, für die man
nix kann, weil
keine Ahnung, die
Abteilung, die das
mit dem, damit
machen muss, irgendwie zu
lahm ist, ja, also, mal angenommen,
man
braucht Zertifikate für eine
Domain, und irgendwie hat man
Verzögerung und kann nix dafür, so.
Der andere weiß das,
und er
weiß auch eigentlich,
woran's liegt,
nämlich, dass
die andere Abteilung zu lahm ist,
so.
Anstatt, dass der im Vorfeld
fragt, so nach dem Motto, sag mal hier, ich hab
gesehen, die Zertifikate sind immer noch nicht da,
ähm, ist das
immer noch so,
dass das an den anderen hängt,
ja, das wär okay gewesen,
nee, die Leute,
so, das ist jetzt wie gesagt so ein Beispiel, wie das
bei manchen Leuten bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
gelaufen ist, die Leute haben dann gewartet,
bis das, bis das
Weekly-Status-Meeting dazu ist,
haben absichtlich
vergessen wieder,
dass sie eigentlich wissen,
dass es nicht an denen liegt,
die das Zertifikat beantragt haben,
sondern an denen, die das Zertifikat
ausstellen, die vergessen, oder die
erwähnen das, diese Meeting nicht,
ähm, und sagen dann
auf dem Meeting sowas wie,
ich sehe, Gruppe XY
ist immer noch mit den Zertifikaten
im Verzug, äh, unter diesen
Bedingungen können wir selbstverständlich
unsere Software, äh, nicht zeitgemäß
deployen. Genau in dem
Ton und genau in, in dieser
Wortwahl und Variante, so
in der Richtung wurde das da gesagt.
Und,
genau, also, Leute, die Betonung,
die Aussprache und alles,
das diente nur dazu,
einfach nur
richtig
krass die Leute abzufacken.
Das war der einzige Sinn
dahinter.
Meistens konntest du das ja, meistens
konntest du das natürlich ganz gut kontern,
äh, wenn du eben dann erzählst,
ich hab dir doch letzte Woche das sogar noch gezeigt.
Ja, wenn du dann gesagt hast, guck mal,
wir haben doch letzte Woche sogar uns
das Ticket zusammen angeguckt.
Du weißt doch, was Sache ist, ja?
Jetzt erzähl ich so Zeug.
Ja, das, das geht, aber dass du das
überhaupt machen musstest, ist halt für'n
Arsch, ja? Oder was noch
geiler ist, mein Lieblingsbeispiel,
bestes Beispiel vom alten Arbeitgeber
war, das hab ich euch schon mal erzählt, oder?
Der Change Manager, der keine
Changes managen wollte.
Hahaha.
Das weiß ich noch.
Ich glaub, das hab ich euch schon erzählt.
Ähm, nur so ganz, nur so ganz
grob, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob
ich's noch überhaupt richtig zusammenkriege.
Wir hatten irgendeine Wartungsrunde,
so,
weekly, weekly
weekly Wartungsrunde,
und
jemand aus meinem Team damals, also
ein Kollege von mir, hatte einen Change
eingestellt.
So, ich hab den Change in der Wartungsrunde
angekündigt, weil es
mussten ja nicht alle Leute selbst, ich hab den
Change in der Wartungsrunde angekündigt,
so, und dann kam dann einer dieser Leute, die
immer nerven mussten um die Ecke,
und meinten dann so, ja,
also ich hab gesehen,
dieser Change, der
findet ja um irgendwie
1 Uhr nachts statt, und das ist aus
seiner Sicht ja auch ein sehr kritischer
Change, ähm,
habt ihr dann auch sichergestellt,
dass jemand vom, ähm,
von der Qualitätssicherung nachts
da ist und das dann direkt mal
kurz testen kann?
Wo ich sag, nee, das haben wir nicht
sichergestellt, wir sind nicht für
die Totalplanung der Qualitätssicherung
zuständig, das ist unter anderem
eines der Gründe, warum es diese
warum es diese, diese Change-Runde
gibt, dass wenn es noch
zusätzliche Anforderungen an, an
extra Leute gibt, dass das dann
vom Change-Management
und unter anderem halt auch demjenigen,
der es gesagt hat, übernommen wird,
und dann meinte der Typ so zu mir,
also der ist zwar ein Change-Manager, ja,
der hätte eigentlich dann hingehen müssen
und sagen, ja, ich hätte gern jemand dabei,
hätte zum Betriebsrat gehen müssen und fragen,
dürfen die nachts Einsatz machen?
Das wäre eigentlich seine Aufgabe gewesen, ne?
Und dann meinte er so, nee, das wäre
nicht seine Aufgabe, wir sollen
doch mal jemand von den, von der
Qualitätssicherung fragen
und dann auf ihn zukommen.
Und da, da musste, da haben wir
uns da auch bestimmt 10 Minuten rumgezankt,
dass das
nicht die Aufgabe dessen ist, der
die Technik macht.
Also, wie gesagt, der Change
an sich war ja gar nicht von
uns. Wir hatten nur
einen Part in diesem Change, nämlich,
ich glaube, es war, ich glaube,
es war sogar ein Kubernetes-Cluster-Upgrade.
Das ist, das ist ein Webinterface
in Azure, dreimal klicken und warten, bis es durch ist.
Ich glaube, es war sogar ein Kubernetes-Update.
Und,
das ist, das ist nicht unser Change.
Wir haben, wir haben einen
Teil dieses Changes, und den stelle ich hier
jetzt vor, das ist das Upgrade des Kubernetes-Clusters.
Und wenn Change-Management sagt,
wir brauchen dann Leute dazu,
ja, dann mach doch.
Das ist,
dann mach doch.
Ich meine, ich habe es dir doch jetzt gesagt, du bist
Change-Manager, wir sind in der Change-Rolle,
dann frag die doch. Nein, nein,
das ist nicht meine Aufgabe,
kümmert euch doch mal drum,
dass wir jemand von der Qualitätssicherung
beibekommen, und dann sollen wir
auf ihn zukommen. Da habe ich auch gesagt,
nö, mach ich nicht.
Da haben wir uns richtig 10 Minuten in den Haken gehabt.
Und das war so witzig im Nachhinein,
weil, mich haben sogar
Leute nebenbei, also
von diesem Change-Manager, der
keine Changes managen will, das habe ja nicht ich gesagt,
während wir da diskutiert haben, haben mich
noch 2, 3 Leute oder sowas angeschrieben,
im Teams, und haben
mehr oder weniger das Gleiche geschrieben, so
lol, wo sind wir denn hier gelandet, Alter?
Change-Manager, der keine
Changes managen will.
Das war komplett unabhängig davon, ja?
Und,
und es wurde
folgendermaßen dann geregelt,
es wurde folgendermaßen dann geregelt,
ein anderer Change-Manager, der
eigentlich für den Bereich gar nicht so richtig
zuständig war, der aber auch in der
Wartungsrunde war, der die Wartungsrunde quasi
geleitet hat, hat gesagt, wisst ihr
was, wir machen das so,
ich guck mir das Ticket nachher
mal an und lad die
Beteiligten ein. Fertig.
Das musste irgendjemand
anderes machen, aber der andere Typ, der
exakt, wirklich genau
dafür da war, sowas zu machen,
wollte einfach nicht.
Und ich hab's nicht eingesehen
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt,
dass man sich als jemand, der quasi
nur ein Teil, der,
der, sagen wir mal, einen der technischen
Parts von dem Gesamt-Change
durchführt, dass der
auf einmal verantwortlich dafür sein soll,
dass Tester einen Nachteinsatz
machen. Das ist
nicht, dass wir eines Technikers,
der nachts einen Change macht, sich um
um den kompletten Change-Ablauf
zu kümmern. Der ist dafür da,
seinen Teil ordentlich zu
planen, vorzubereiten, zu dokumentieren,
anzukündigen und sonst nix.
Ich mein,
dafür hast du ja Leute, die sich explizit um diesen
Change-Prozess kümmern.
Das war witzig, der Change-Manager, der keine
Changes managen wollte.
Das war auch so ein Kandidat,
Alter, ich sag euch,
das war auch so einer.
Du hast das Gefühl, der hat immer nur was gesagt,
um sich mal wieder ins Gespräch zu bringen.
Bei euch auf der Arbeit gibt es einen Admin,
der sich nicht auf die Server einloggen will.
Was administriert
er denn eigentlich, wenn er sich nicht auf den
Server einloggen will?
Ist ein Admin ohne sich auf den Server einloggen
eigentlich ein Admin?
PotatoBob, ich hab PotatoCop gelesen
erst, PotatoBob schreibt,
ist wie unser
Anforderungsmanager,
der die Anforderungen immer ungefragt
an den Entwickler gibt, damit er sagt,
ja, das ist auch geil.
Ich denke mir halt, in so einer Position,
dass er nicht alles alleine wissen und machen
und schreiben kann, verstehe ich ja,
aber dann soll er sich halt mal ein paar Leute,
viele in dieser Position
vergessen, dass Manager
oftmals ja gar nicht heißt, dass sie es selber
machen müssen, sondern dass sie
managen müssen, unter anderem, dass die
richtigen Leute zusammenkommen.
Manager bedeutet ja oftmals nicht, mache den
Scheiß selber, sondern
besorg dir die Leute und bring die Leute an
einen Tisch, die wissen, was sie machen
und im Zweifelsfall schreib dann halt das Ergebnis
zusammen, oder lass dir die Teile liefern
und schreib ein schönes
Gesamtkunstwerk da draus.
Weil ansonsten, wenn ein Manager
nicht managt,
dann brauchst du ihn ja auch nicht,
weil dafür ist ja ein Manager da.
Du brauchst auch keinen Teamleiter,
wenn er das, oder kein Team, ja,
Gruppenmanager, Gruppenleiter, wie auch immer
sein, wenn der das Team nicht
vertritt, wenn er einfach nur da ist,
dann brauchst du ihn nicht.
Dann muss das Team vertreten,
sowohl gegenüber dem Team
die Entscheidung von oben und umgedreht,
aber auch, wenn es Probleme gibt, nach oben.
Und einem nach Möglichkeit halt
auch den Rücken frei halten, wenn es um
Entscheidungen geht, dass man nicht selbst
Dinge machen muss, die man vielleicht
gar nicht machen darf und sowas.
Da muss ich sagen, da hatte ich tatsächlich
fast immer Glück,
also auch mein aktueller Chef,
also der
aktuelle, beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
aber auch die davor,
die waren tatsächlich alle nicht übel.
Mein aktueller Chef hat
vielleicht einen, zumindest muss ich mich dann auch dran gewöhnen,
vielleicht einen kleinen,
so ein bisschen zu sehr
Hands-off-Approach,
ich weiß nicht, wie man das sonst nennen mag,
aber der hat dann auch sehr viele Leute.
Also von dem kriegt man sehr wenig mit.
Der mietet eigentlich den ganzen Tag und man sieht den
hauptsächlich in, ja,
zweimal in der Teamrunde, so nach dem Motto.
Ja gut,
und klar, man kann ja
im Teams anschreiben und meistens meldet er sich dann auch,
aber ansonsten kriegt man nicht viel mit,
man muss sich seine Arbeit mehr oder weniger selbst organisieren.
Was ich auch eigentlich
ganz gut finde, aber
ich weiß nicht, ab und zu mal vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr mitkriegen könnte man schon.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es auch gut,
ja, dass man machen kann, was man will.
Ich weiß nicht, es ist also eine Sache, aber
ich kriege glaube ich eh demnächst bald
einen neuen Chef.
Ähm, ja.
Aber da kann ich jetzt nicht zu viel erzählen, weil intern ist Zeug.
Aber Leute, es gibt
immer was zu meckern, ja, also
insgesamt kann ich mich aber echt nicht beschweren,
also sowohl bei meinem aktuellen Chef als auch bei den letzten,
die haben sich alle Mühe gegeben.
Wo ich echt
Probleme hatte, ist damals beim Provider mit meinem
Chef und beim
alten Arbeitgeber mit den ersten Paar,
die ich da hatte. Also da hatte ich wirklich Probleme,
aber die letzten paar Jahre über
haben sich eigentlich alle Mühe gegeben.
Was ihnen teilweise sogar zum Verhängnis
geworden ist. Also einer meiner ehemaligen Chefs
wurde ja quasi
gekickt für zu oft
Widerspruch. Der hat das halt
wirklich vertreten, was man ihm gesagt hat, ja.
So nach dem Motto,
was
Probleme macht und
was trotz
Kommunikation nicht besser geworden ist, das hat er dann auch immer so
erzählt und wahrscheinlich ist ihm das
zum Verhängnis geworden. Und da hat er dann auch
gesagt, ich weiß, also
einen meiner ehemaligen Chefs haben sie ja wirklich
rausgeekelt aus der Firma und
eines der Gründe dafür
muss gewesen sein,
also ist so meine Vermutung,
dass er halt
gesagt hat,
dass die Umsetzung von Homeoffice
ich weiß, also
ich sag euch jetzt mal, wie ich denke, dass er es
gemeint hat. Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie er es wirklich gesagt hat.
Also er hat es,
er hat sinngemäß wahrscheinlich sowas gesagt,
wie, dass die Umsetzung
hier in dem Unternehmen
nicht auf sehr viel,
nicht auf positive Resonanz
bei seinen Leuten
stößt.
Das muss er wohl auch öfters mal angesprochen haben.
Jedes Mal, wenn
da dran rumgedoktert wurde
an den Regelungen, dass das halt eben
nicht gut ankommt. Und da hat er auch recht.
Ich mein, das ist eigentlich auch was, was ich erwartet habe.
Was ich erwarten würde von einem Teamleiter,
von einem Gruppenleiter, je nachdem, wie man es nennen mag,
dass der, wenn es so Probleme
gibt, dass der das auch schon weitergibt.
Ich mein, wo ist denn der Sinn davon, wenn du
alles verschweigst und dann werden
ja irgendwie Entscheidungen getroffen, die nichts
mit der Realität zu tun haben. Das kann ja auch nicht
sein.
Im umgedrehten Fall,
wenn man dann sagt, okay, ja,
wir haben gehört, dass das den Leuten nicht gefällt, wir machen
es trotzdem, dann muss der das auch
genauso verkaufen. Dann muss er sagen,
Leute, ich hab das
gebracht, wollen sie nicht, wir müssen das
so und so machen. Vorgabe.
Das muss der als Teamleiter hinkriegen.
Das muss der in beide Richtungen auf die Reihe kriegen.
Und es müssen dann auch dem seine Vorgesetzten
das aushalten, dass der halt mal sagt,
was Sache ist. Und das haben
die nicht ausgehalten bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Also es wurde einem
meiner ehemaligen Chefs zum Verhängnis,
dass der sich wohl
da auf
Veranstaltungen, die Führungskräfte
Meetings
wohl offen gesagt hat,
keiner mag eure Homeoffice-Regelungen,
die ihr da gerade macht. Also das hat er nicht so gesagt,
aber er hat das so gemeint, ja.
Und das war halt schlicht ergreifend
komplett die Wahrheit.
Und das wurde ihm zum Verhängnis.
Das wollten sie nicht hören.
Und das waren ja nicht nur wir, das waren ja viele Teams.
Weiß nicht, ob er das darf.
Ja, dann ist auch kein Admin mehr.
Aktuell ähnliches Problem. Scrum Master will sich nicht
um agile Probleme kümmern,
die er verbockt hat.
Kommt drauf an, was das für Probleme sind.
Also der Scrum Master ist ja
eigentlich nur dafür da,
um, ja gut, eigentlich genau
für sowas, dass diese
agile
Arbeitsweise
irgendwie etabliert wird, gecoacht wird,
eingehalten wird. Ich kenne die offizielle Definition
davon nicht. Deswegen darf ja eigentlich
auch ein Scrum Master kein Projektleiter
oder sowas sein. Leider wird das oftmals
ein bisschen vermischt, was dann wieder keinen Sinn ergibt,
weil der Projektleiter ganz andere
Interessen als der Scrum Master hat.
Aber ja, eigentlich ist das schon
so ein bisschen die Aufgabe.
Weil manche haben auch zwei Sachen. Manche haben quasi
einen Scrum Master
und manche haben dann
noch zusätzlich einen, jetzt haltet euch fest,
einen Agile Coach.
Weiß nicht, habt ihr auch schon mal
ein Agile Coaching
gehabt?
Ich hatte schon mal ein Agiles Coaching.
Und das war gar nicht schlecht.
Das ist, okay, kurz gesagt,
das ist ein Typ, der da sitzt, meistens von irgendeiner
Beraterfirma und
weil er schon in so vielen Unternehmen war,
die agile Sachen versucht haben
einzuführen und zu machen und zu leben,
weiß der halt Bescheid und kann einem
Ratschläge geben, wenn was nicht gut klappt.
Also,
ja, ich hatte
schon mal ein Projekt mit einem agilen Coach
und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das war gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich war ja am Anfang sehr
skeptisch der ganzen
Sache übereingestellt, weil ich mir
gedacht habe, Alter, jetzt haben sie wieder irgendeinen externen Typ
hier hingesetzt, der dir sonst was erzählt,
was mit den Abläufen hier überhaupt nichts zu tun hat.
Aber ich muss sagen, das war
eines der wenigen Consultants und
eines der wenigen so, ähm,
wir wollen uns krass verbessern
und wir machen jetzt was,
wo tatsächlich ganz gut gewesen ist.
Am Ende hat es nichts gebracht,
weil nichts von dem, was wir da vorgeschlagen
und erarbeitet haben, je gemacht wurde.
Aber
der Typ an sich war nicht verkehrt.
Hi Max, ich bin seit gestern mit meinem Netzwerk
Admin-Kurs fertig. Die Juniorstelle
in einer Nähe fragt, Moment, die
Juniorstellen in meiner Nähe fragen dennoch
nach Berufserfahrung, trotzdem, klar,
warum nicht, schadet doch nichts.
Die können sich das
Du hast doch Berufserfahrung, wenn du
erst, äh, erst, wenn du, ähm, First und Second
Level Support machst.
Du hast doch Berufserfahrung.
Berufserfahrung heißt ja nicht zwangsläufig,
dass du Erfahrung haben
musst in exakt 100%
Match, was die haben wollen.
Darfst du den Consultant
nennen? Ich wüsste nicht, warum ich
ihn nicht nennen darf. Ich weiß nämlich nicht, ob ich den
nennen will. Und ich weiß aus dem Kopf
auch gar nicht mehr, wie diese Consulting-Klitsche
überhaupt hieß. Also,
du hast doch Berufserfahrung.
Das ja. Also ich würde mich
auf jeden Fall bewerben, wenn das was ist, was du machen
willst. Und ich kann dir sagen,
viele Unternehmen sind aktuell
auch nicht sonderlich wählerisch.
Was
gut ist, auch, weil
ich bin eh der Meinung, dass sie oftmals
ein bisschen zu sehr aussortieren.
Weil
es ist gar nicht so wichtig,
dass die Leute so 100% darauf passen.
Es ist wichtig, dass es
ein Thema ist, was die Leute irgendwie
begeistert und dass die
einarbeitungswillig sind
und Bock drauf haben.
Das ist eigentlich fast das Wichtigste.
Also ich
würde beispielsweise auch eine Netzwerk-Admin
einstellen, wenn
er mir sagt, ich hab
die letzten 15 Jahre Cisco gemacht,
aber wir machen
irgendeinen anderen Hersteller.
Also das kriegt er schon hin mit der Zeit.
Also ich würde das machen.
Und nachdem die
aktuell eh nicht so wählerisch sind,
wenn du gut passt, sollen sie dich
einarbeiten, was auf jeden Fall unterm Strich
angenehmer ist, als jemand, der
alles 100% kann, aber mit dem man nicht auskommt.
Ding erinnern.
Excellent. Ich muss auch gleich ins Bett.
Excellent.
Woher das agile Gerede
kommt, weil das seit ein paar Jahren so
ein Trend ist, dass alle agil sein wollen.
Und ich glaube kaum einer von denen
hat sich mal
dieses
agile Manifest, was es
seit Jahrzehnten schon gibt,
auch nur die ersten paar Dinge angeguckt.
Und wenn das nicht,
ich muss sagen, groß gelesen habe ich das auch nicht,
es gibt aber einen Vortrag da drüber
von einem
der Mitunterzeichner
dieser ganzen ursprünglichen
Sache. Und der
lässt kein gutes Haar an,
was aktuell
diese agile Geschichte geworden ist.
Also eines der ursprünglichen
Gedanken hinter dieser ganzen
Agilitätssache ist ja,
dass sich Programmierer weniger
mit Managern auseinandersetzen müssen.
Das ist eines der zentralen
Gedanken schlechthin. Also dieses
wir machen agil in der Administration
und sowas, ergibt eigentlich
kaum einen Sinn, zumindest
nach der ursprünglichen
Idee.
Also eines der zentralen Sachen von dieser
agilen Idee sagt auch einer der
ursprünglichen Unterzeichner selbst war,
dass sich Programmierer
weniger mit Manager
diskutieren müssen.
Um Manager aus der täglichen Programmierarbeit
rauszuhalten. Das
war eines der ursprünglichen Gedanken davon.
Und
daher kommt ja auch das mit Sprints
und sowas, so nach dem Motto, okay
Product
Owner und Manager und hast du nicht
gesehen, die können
alle 14 Tage
alle 2 Monate, wie auch immer
zusammensetzen und das Projekt steuern.
Aber das
Umsetzen der Aufgaben dann in diesem Sprint
das dürfen die Programmierer selbst organisieren.
Also nichts mehr mit täglichem
Statusbericht beim Chef und
bei Daily Meetings
Projektmanager dabei, der sagt
ah das und das hier müssen wir jetzt noch anpassen und das
und das heute ist wichtig. Also das war
eines der ursprünglichen
Gedanken hinter
dieser ganzen Agile Geschichte.
Es gibt zig Methoden davon
mittlerweile. Ehrlich
gesagt, ich halte von den wenigsten
dieser ganzen Frameworks
oder auch Zertifizierungen
und sowas
was, es muss
zum jeweiligen Unternehmen passen.
Man kann sich sicherlich irgendwelche Frameworks
nehmen und daraus sich das raussuchen
was gut passt. Man sollte
allerdings nicht auf die Idee kommen,
man muss jetzt den kompletten Laden umstrecken,
was eh nicht geht, weil das meist nur einzelne
Projekte sind. Ähm,
um das alles hundertprozentig zu
erfüllen.
Das muss passen.
Gute Idee. Ja, da hört's
halt bei vielen schon auf. So nach dem
Motto, da kann dann das
Management verkaufen, wir sind super agil,
wir haben jetzt agile Methodik eingeführt.
Ja, was macht ihr denn? Äh,
wir haben 5 Jira Tickets.
Die wenigsten machen das
nach der, also ich muss
ja sagen, was heißt die wenigsten?
Bei keinem, wo ich bisher
gewesen bin,
hat man es geschafft,
die ursprüngliche Idee
hinter
dieser ganzen agilen
Geschichte
einzuführen,
beziehungsweise zu etablieren.
Man hat irgendwas versucht zu machen, weil
agil jeder macht und agil cool klingt
und dann kam im Endeffekt
irgendwas raus, was eigentlich
mehr oder weniger so ist wie
immer, nur dass es jetzt agil
heißt.
Ja, und das sieht man zum Beispiel
schon daran, wenn man auf die
Idee kommt, der Scrum Master ist
gleichzeitig auch im Projektmanagement.
Das widerspricht sich einfach
grundsätzlich. Das kann,
wenn man das richtig machen will, gar nicht funktionieren.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Aber wird oftmals gemacht.
Da muss ich sagen, tatsächlich
bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber,
das ist ja, also ich bin ja da auch
zum größten Teil in einem Projekt
unterwegs, wo es tatsächlich um
Blockchain-Technologie geht.
Ja gut, nach fünf Jahren hat das jetzt
eine Versicherung auch mal mitbekommen, dass das
was Cooles ist. Das dauert immer ein bisschen.
So in der Finanzbranche, die sind da nicht so schnell.
Und die
geben sich tatsächlich
Mühe, das nicht so
einfach nur agil
zu branden, sondern
sie versuchen das wirklich in irgendeiner Art und Weise
mit
Sprints und Einteilen
und so. Und auch der,
der Manager, oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob es der Projektmanager ist,
die geben sich tatsächlich Mühe.
Das Problem ist nur,
dass es auch nur
beschränkt hilft,
wenn ein Projekt
jetzt möglichst agil sein will,
aber alles andere drum herum
ist oldschool
Finanzbranche as fuck.
Mit dreifachen Durchschlägen und
100 Genehmigungen.
Also sobald du nicht
mehr das Reihenprojekt
intern handeln kannst, wird das eh nix.
Mit Agilität
in dem Fall.
Und wir können halt sehr vieles nicht projektintern
handeln.
Weil
naja
das halt einfach nicht unser Bier ist.
Ja.
Aber sie geben sich zumindest Mühe.
Sie geben sich mehr Mühe als
davor.
Bei der alten Kiste. So wieso noch wach? Leute ich muss
jetzt ins Bett. Morgen früh wieder aufstehen.
Wir sehen uns und morgen müssen wir uns echt mal
die Apple Zusammenfassung angucken.
Das hab ich heute nicht mehr auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Macht's gut bis dann. See you.